and all right you all set to get
going all right ladies and gentlemen my
name is will infantine on the chairman
of the labor committee I needed to I
need to read the Chairman's script
here Christina we have a little
feedback Len okay thank you as chairman
of the labor industrial and
rehabilitative service committee I find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order
2020-4
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee an
executive session may
follow please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate and temporaneous during the
meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice of this
meeting the notice for this meeting
notice complies with house rule RSA
91a anyone who has problems ask
accessing the meeting should call
271 3600 that's
271-3600 or email
HCS ledge. state. n. us that's
HCS lg. state. n.
Us in the event of the enable to access
the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and resched
Christina Dyer is assisting us
today please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by roll call
vote uh let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member State pres please also State
whether or not there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
La thank
you
here seaworth oh I'm I'm here in the
room with committee room with a number
of Representatives which I will
introduce
shortly
I Mr
around pres in the
n
Warden
room I'm here alone in the
room I'm here and I'm uh at the labor
board
meeting
Sullivan I am here in my home office in
gram
room
Rudy I am here and I am alone in the
alone
sylvestro I am here and
alone we could barely hear you Linda I
am here and alone thank
you I am here alone in my own
office to me here alone at
alone thank you representative just for
the record folks the individuals in the
um committee room are representative
Huff representative turot representative
seaward representative Cullen
representative Macky representative
adjudant who uh just stepped out briefly
and myself representative infanti the
remaining individuals are online uh in
keeping with the tradition I would
appreciate uh at least everyone here
standing we're going to pledge
allegiance representative Seward if you
would lead us in the pledge I'd
appreciate it yes Mr
chair I pledge allegiance to the flag
the United States of
America for which it stands one nation
and God indivisible liberty and justice
for
all as you see in the calendar I've
tried to separate some uh some time so
we do have a break me ten uh I it up my
my um Calendar please uh we do have a
break for lunch as well as a break in
the morning uh I do have the list of
what we call pink and blue cards and
there are approximately two or three
speakers uh for
each bill uh and then I will recite who
who is uh after each bill I will recite
who is um signed in and either uh in
favor or
opposed we do have I said is the break
for lunch for anyone who wants to come
in here understand please uh there's no
cafeteria we have to go off site we do
have a break between um the 10 o'clock
hearing and the 11 so hopefully we can
uh that'll only last half an hour of
time for people to take bathroom breaks
and get something to eat if they will uh
in a conversation yesterday or the day
before with representative Sullivan in
the calendar it does state that we could
have executive session uh and I will
just uh reiterate what I have said uh to
representative Sullivan and to you folks
during the orientation I do not like
having executive sessions on the same
day a bill is heard I do not think we're
going to have to have that um I would
let anyone know in advance if that would
occur we have one bill that has to be
out early uh and I think we'll be fine I
just don't like doing that because I
think sometimes after a hearing
something can come out the next day
people think about things um and I just
don't like to push it that way so
although it is stated there in the
calendar uh I will not I will endeavor
at all cost not to do that
have any kind of executive session the
same day
um it's very difficult for me to see I'm
not looking at the computer screen the
regular Zoom screen that I could be able
to see you when you are raising your
hand hopefully at the next hearing I'll
be able to exactly what Christina is
seeing um um but uh please be patient we
are doing the best we can with all of
this I've taken a number of Zoom classes
and and what have you but it's not going
to be perfect I tried to pick some
simpler bills today that didn't have as
many
um uh speakers and such so we could get
so any questions before we have we I
hearing right not seeing any thank you
very much folks we're going to I guess
open the house session uh house hearing
on House Bill
259 and I would call on representative
uh yella to introduce his
Bill thank you Mr chairman thank you
members of the committee I'm here uh my
name is for the record my name is uh
Josh yella uh representative from
Fremont uh and I'm here presenting HB
259 relative to employee
uniforms the goal of this legislation is
for uh what can can be uh conflict
between what an employee might want and
what a
employer is able to offer under the law
um the
employee uh uniform leg statute right
now defines uniform as a garment with a
company logo or fashion of distinctive
design worn by more one or more
employees and serving as a means of
identification or distinction and so if
if a garment has a distinctive logo and
is not really available for public
use um then you could essentially Define
that as an employee uniform and there
are
options uh sometimes offered by
companies in other states that are
premium
or or the employee just wants to have as
many or more employee uniforms than the
employer would like to provide for free
because
of um ease of you know maybe they don't
want to wash their clothes as much or
you know whatever situation that they
might have um the employee off requiring
the employee
to only be given uh uniforms for
free uh requires that amount of overhead
for the employer so the employer is
going to want to limit you know the
employee uniforms offered for free to a
limited um reasonable whatever they deem
as reasonable amount but that may not be
the same reasonable amount for the
employee and or there may
be uh options that are premium that
might cost um a small amount of money
more than the normal uh employee
uniforms that the employer might not
want to eat the whole cost of and so in
New Hampshire right now if those premium
options are available but only required
by law to be given for free the
employer sometimes chooses to not offer
them at all in this state um this
creates some tension because you know
they might be able to see a person or
employee in another state having options
to buy you know sweaters or jackets or
whatever that the public is not
available to buy and has this
distinctive design that sets them apart
from from the normal people in the
store and therefore are defined as
employee
uniforms and so the goal is to just add
some language that allows for some
selling of additional uniforms or
optional Alternatives that the offered
by the company um at some fee um
obviously you you want to encourage the
employer to to give the the standard
uniform but what it what about optional
or additional um pairs of of
uniforms uh that that the um employer
might not want
to eat the cost of as the overhead uh
for for its employ
employes um I think that that the
employees should be able to have that
option if they chose um obviously it's
not required but that's why I proposed
this legislation today and I hope that
you will be able to support that and I'm
happy to answer any
questions thank you
representative Miss Dy are there any are
representatives I don't see any hands
raised but I can't tell whether there's
yes thank you um representative um could
you envision a situation where an
employer might offer a flimsy t-shirt as
a u uniform a single flimsy
t-shirt and then um offer for sale some
um nice collared shirts some sweaters or
sweatshirts colder uh temperatures um
and um basically require all uh
employees to wear the uniform but the
employees would uh recognize that the
t-shirt is undesirable and so all
virtually all employees would be forced
into a situation of having to buy their
uniform um because the flimsy t-shirt is
wear thank you uh for the question
um yes I guess it is potentially
possible for um someone to offer
some lower
quality uh for free but
the the law does state that it needs to
be reasonably suited for the conditions
um of which the employee would be
required to wear one so if it was an
argument could be made that if it was
you know extremely cold or whatever then
a flimsy t-shirt might not be reasonably
suited if they need to you know go
outside or whatever um so an argument
can be made about how how
reasonable
um that that
uh would be suited to the
job already in in
statute
okay representative I see hand
representative kahill yes thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
yella for bringing the bill forward I do
have a question uh does not the the uh
existence of a premium and a and a sub
premium or standard is that is it are
they not uniform in this
case they're not the
same
so so thank you for the question um the
uniform definition says anything that is
distinctive um
or has the logo and as a means of
identification or distinctive and
so um the
uniform it's kind of a very broad option
and I've worked at places that do have
um a standard uniform and then they have
you know Christmas options where you
could wear the regular t-shirt or you
could wear a t-shirt with you know a
reef on it or you could get a you if you
were cold you could get a fleece or
something like that and it would still
it still looks kind of the same um and
still identifies you as being an
employee of the company and not just a
regular person standing in the store um
but it is kind of optional you don't
have to wear that you could wear the
regular one without the Christmas you
it can comes in practice I think that um
it is a uniform or it's definitely under
this definition because it's so broad
however it is there are some flexibility
offered in some companies on what the
the uniform should
entail uh followup follow yes thank you
Mr chairman yes I I appreciate having
the the logo or the distinctive design
is in that much is uniform but uh could
you tell me if this is a common problem
Hampshire
um thank you for the question
um I I was not really uh aware of this
issue until it was brought to my
attention um I
in the in the times that I uh was
working they because I was working in
New Hampshire they just offered what
they can offer um it's only comes
into to play I think where where
employees are frustrated when they you
know go to a company website or they go
to another location perhaps working out
of the state and see more options or or
just visit another States um
um uh location and then they say wait a
minute where why are these options
available and then the um and then
there's also the frustration on the uh
employer side to not be able to offer
everything that the company is offering
to other employees and puts the New
Hampshire at a disadvantage I'm not sure
it applies to all companies in this
state but it
would it would only create kind of a a
conflict between the employer and the
employee where the employee the company
has other locations outside of the state
also because they would be have
different rules than than the ones in
this state so it would be only only
companies that
are are more widespread than just in New
Hampshire that helps give give an
example of how many people are affected
all right thank you I have a question
from representative turkot then I think
representative Bard representative turot
um thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
representative
representative pill just asked the exact
question I was going to and I just heard
the answer question about how common of
a problem is it so don't have question
thank you representative turkot is that
representative buard had your hand yes
thank you Mr chairman and representative
so and I can't recognize the faith to
the name uh gentlemen who is raising
their hand I think like Mr Prout Mr
uh yeah hold on to ask a question go
ahead sir thank you Mr chairman um
representative ell you mentioned that
companies exclude uh New Hampshire
employees from buying these options from
The Company Store do you know how many
States these companies operate in and
how many other states um they allow
their employees to buy this I mean are
we looking at a situation where 49
states this is allowed and we're the
only one or is it more like 5050 or do
you have any information like
that um
I did not have that information in in
front of me I they they operate in all
50 states the the person that brought
this to my attention um their company
operates in all 50 States but I did not
uh research that and I would hap be
happy to uh follow up with you on that
that question thank
you representative Warden has his hand
up oh just a moment I have
representative huff and then
representative Warden representative
Huff thank you Mr chairman uh
representative uh yala is there a
penalty Associated for non-compliance
with
this
that is a good question I did not see
one in this statute however these these
people are
um they have to have a a license through
the the board of Labor so I think that
the board of labor would
would have the punishments uh set up
there um that might be a better question
for for the Department
thank you the department will be
speaking afterwards is that uh you also
that with your question representative H
representative Warden thank you
representative yella in reading the
existing statute it says an employee May
purchase any other company garments or
items if the employee chooses so it
sounds like already they can buy
additional garments as long as they pay
for it can you explain for us why this
new language is needed exactly what is
the
difference yes thank you for the
question uh So based on the reading of
um employ company garments um that would
be obviously something that is not does
not have a company logo or distinctive
design
that serves as a means of identification
or distinction so if it was uh allowed
to be purchased by
everyone then it would would not fall
under
the the um definition of
uniform so if it's only for employees
then it would be would fall under the
definition of uniform if it was not if
it was open to the general public then
it would be considered a company garment
or
item okay thank you right thank you we
we have uh more questions that I can see
in the room are online uh we have one
more person to testify fight is coming
up at 9:25 so unless there's any further
questions uh thank you representative
for uh submitting your your bill thank
you next up who has signed up to speak
is uh Rudolph Ogden the New Hampshire
Department of Labor assistant
commissioner uh commissioner uh Ogden
us yes can you all hear me yes we can um
thank you chairman for the record my
name is Rudy Ogden Deputy Commissioner
of the Department of Labor um we did
want to speak to this bill and
representative yoka was kind enough to
share the language of this bill and talk
to us um before presenting it just in
terms of context one thing I would note
and seeing many familiar faces the folks
that were on this Committee in
2018 will remember that this particular
language uh surrounding
27548 5B was amended in 2018 then
representative uh Keith Murphy who's in
the restaurant industry had actually had
a lot to do relative to this language
and the specific thing he was trying to
accomplish and I don't mean to put words
in his mouth but when we were talking
about this language about an employee
May purchase any other company garments
or items the intent was to allow for if
you have an employer that says you have
to wear a polo shirt or a t-shirt but
the employees on their own want to wear
fleeces or other options
uh they could purchase those and those
would not have to be provided by the
employer so understanding representative
Warden and yla's discussion right there
I understand there might be some
confusion around the language of that
but I will say that was the intent of
those terms the thought of putting that
language in in 2018 and the Department's
application of that language since 2018
has been to say that individual
employees if they wanted to could buy
what you might consider these alter
alternative or premium options I did say
to representative Uka if we were going
to bring up any type of concern or
question relative to this language it
would just be in reference to the uh
inclusion of the language quote
including additional uniforms uh the
Department's one concern with that would
be is that if the employer is to say I
want you to wear a t-shirt or a polo
shirt here is one uh polo shirt or one
t-shirt and you're supposed to work five
or seven shifts a week that might become
impractical to the point where that
employee then has to go out and purchase
additional uh uniforms in order to make
it work I would note and I'll be very
candid in acknowledging that the
language of the statute does not provide
a specific number which I think does
sometimes lead to issues of what is
enough because to representative yok's
Point some employers might want to give
three and some employees might want to
get eight I will say that uh that is
been something that has come up in the
past as a point of tension uh just how
many should be provided in practice the
department tripic tries to say what is a
practical number whether that be three
to five of whatever the Garment is um so
I just point that out as as something
I'm happy to answer any questions that
folks have the one I did hear from
representative Huff is was there or
could there be penalties If an employer
was in violation of this there could be
penalties the department has G General
penalty Powers uh if there's a violation
of this uh of any of the laws under its
title uh we could issue a fine uh and
that would be after an initial warning
and additionally if there were uh
uniforms purchased um outside of the
bounds of this uh there could
potentially be a wage adjustment where
the employee would be reimbursed for
those
purchases thank you represent ogon I do
have two questions here in the room uh
but I have a question first if I might
the fine would this fall under the
clause in the law where the department
May fine up to
$2500 or is that yeah so that thank you
for the CH uh question chairman the
general penalty powers of the department
it you can there can be a fine of up to
$2500 per
violation thank you I have a question
from representative turot representative
thank you Mr chairman uh good to at
least hear you this morning Rudy you
can't see you but uh thanks for coming
on uh just uh two really quick questions
um the first one is how often do you
receive complaints on this section of
the uh the labor law and the second
question would be have you ever as a
labor department to your knowledge ever
given out any
penalties uh on this section so in terms
of how common this is I do not think
it's that common the instances I'm most
directly aware of I won't name the
employers uh but we have done
inspections and it's to the earlier
point on weather conditions where an
employer has said you know here's a polo
shirt but you always need to have a
company logo on now go out and uh you
know change the trash at the uh gas uh
pumps and it's you know 30 degrees out
so the people were buying sweatshirts
and jackets so it's most often come up
in those type of circumstances where
there's altered conditions they're
telling the people that they always have
to have a logo on in their only giving
him a t-shirt or a polo shirt in terms
of penalties I can get you the stats on
that we definitely have issued penalties
relative to this but again it's not all
that frequent that we're citing uniform
law thank you thank you representative
Huff I thought your hand my apolog I'm
sorry representative Seward word thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you
commissioner Ogden for for being here
today my question is as I look at this
language um also looked at the written
testimony that the the sponsor provides
us certainly seems to me that he's
addressing the same issue um that we
addressed back in I believe 2018 was the
year you said um and I I'd kind of like
to get your impression it is is that the
feeling you get that the issues that are
being identified now are the ones that
we did address in law and that maybe the
issue is communication to employers that
there has been a change in law what was
not allowable in
2016 is allowable in 2021 do you have
any feeling for that change and maybe
some of the impetus behind um a new bill
on this subject um that's a fair point
representative seaworth I I definitely
think that um if a large part of the
intent of this bill was to address
premium all or alternative options um as
I noted earlier that was in 2018 what
the language was supposed to do was to
allow for premium or alternative options
so certainly I believe that there's uh
that was intended to be addressed in
2018 and as I've said since 2018 when
we've conducted or looked at the any of
these issues we've applied it in the way
that an employer uh could have its
employee purchase these premium or
alternative
options thank you I don't see any hands
up are there any IND Representatives
online representative aini is has his
hand up okay representative aini
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Deputy Commissioner Aron um I do
remember this bill from 18 um could you
clarify if a um business issues a polo
with the logo on their shirt and then
offers a fleece or a premium item maybe
out of their retail line that employees
could
wear however but the employer does not
mandate an outer covering with the logo
on it would that violate this law it
would not correct that was the exam
exact example that was discussed at
testimony in 2018 was this example of
they only ever need to wear the polo
shirt but they the employee on their own
says that they would rather wear the
fleece thank you Deputy Commissioner
thank you Mr
chairman
repres seeing none are there any other
testify
you I'm having trouble hearing you
sir Mr chairman we we might make a clear
that if they want to testify they should
raise their
hand this is for individuals who may
have
on be nice if I had my microphone on oh
yeah there you go can you hear me now I
apologize for
that yes okay there's no one else to
testify uh I'm going to read the two
individuals who have signed in uh Eric
wrath bun a member of the public does
not support the bill and represent
representative
Tom
hes uh an elected official does not
support the
bill seeing no other I think go ahead
representative
seaworth I'm s that backwards they're
not speaking but they are in support
thank you let me reiterate Eric Rathburn
a member of the public did not testify
but supports this uh and representative
of Tom platus uh does support this my
you
do okay seeing no other I'm going to
close no other questions I'm going to
Bill
259 and I'm going to open the hearing on
three
have any representative which
ising the bill did try to sign up
for the online I don't know why it
didn't get me uh I intended to sign up
to introduce both my bills right
representative seaworth you are
recognized to
um introduce your bill House Bill 303
thank you Mr chairman and I apologize um
for the mixup I am the sponsor of
hb303 um just for anybody watching
online I'm going to virtually remove
myself from the uh committee
table uh we can't physically do that
here because of the locations of the
microphones there's nowhere I could
really go away from the table and uh
still be picked up so um for the record
my name is representative Brian seaworth
I live in Pembrook I represent the um
District that includes Penbrook and Chai
Chester and I'm introducing this
bill as language that was suggested by
the
department and at the risk of being a
little verbose and I know imagine that
with me uh I'm I'm going to give a
little more background and that on this
bill because I know having worked on it
uh the language is sometimes confusing
until you understand uh what we're
trying to do here I'll start out the
point is not to change the effect of the
law in any way this is a housekeeping
update to existing law
and it should not be changing how the
law actually works and there's one issue
with that that I'm going to return to at
the end um but where I want to start I
did send around to the committee an
email that had some language in it from
a study committee that took place in the
previous session and um that was a study
committee in fact returning members not
only from last session but from two
sessions ago probably remember how we
got this started uh last year this
committee and then the house and then
the Senate formed a study committee to
look at Labor statutes again the intent
was to look at housekeeping issues not
looking at policy not looking at
political uh issues but is there
language that is out of date or
inconsistent and needs to be
updated um I want to give some credit to
the wisdom of our previous chair
representative Sullivan uh made the S
made two
suggestions that a we limited the scope
of uh what that study committee focused
on and two he suggested that rather than
have members of this committee comb
through all the laws and try to
determine what was um problematic that
we rely on the department of laor who
knows all the issues and all the
language of these laws as well as
anybody for us where there might be
problems and then
the so we did that I think we had um a
successful particularly given some of
the issues of of last year and this was
one of the bills that came out of that
committee recommended for further
legislation
um at this point what I want to do
is talk a little bit about what the law
does emphasizing that this bill won't
change that so first of
all it does three things number one um
it has been the law in New Hampshire for
some 35 years and I I didn't know this
except through my experience on the
committee um many of you probably know
this some don't but if you're an
employee and you are called into work
either is your scheduled to work or
you're you're called up and asked to
come in and you show up to work you must
be paid for two
hours and that includes whether you work
two hours and then get sent home or if
you're if I'm your employer and I say
listen I've got nothing for you to do
today just go home I still owe you two
hour pay even if you haven't worked at
all so that's what this law does number
two and and this went in at the time the
law was originally written there is an
exception for municipal and County
Employees um I actually put in a request
to legislative research which hasn't
been completed yet uh I imagine that
this is a 28a issue that if we mandated
that uh subdivisions pay their
employees something extra the state
would have to fund the cost of of that
extra payment and I assume that's why
that's in here but in any case that
provision applies to all employers
except County and
Municipal third item and this was
introduced much more recently I believe
it was
2016 and addition exception was put into
place and this was for the ski
Industries and snowboard and skiing
instructors they too have an exception
but their exception is different in
their case
um an employee can be paid for the two
hours or can be given
um something in compensation that's
worth at least as much as the pay that
they are owed
and fortunately on our uh study
committee last year we had a
representative former representative
canler had worked as a ski instructor so
he could help us on the committee
understand how this all works and why
it's actually uh something very welcome
by um instructors so I kind of put it in
my own
terms the ski and snowboard instructors
that I know love that job they really
love skiing they love snowboarding they
love teaching other people how to ski
and snowboard and yes they're working
for the money but I think many of them
just getting out there and skiing is a
much part of what why they do it as the
pay so you're scheduled to uh teach some
lessons you show up and there's no
students so sorry you
know nothing for you to do here today um
if I'm your employer I'm going to say
well I've got to pay you for two hours
so uh go over to the maintenance shed
ask Jim if there's any anything you can
have you do because I got to pay you
well that's not why a a ski instructor
is doing that job and so it's actually a
much better deal for him to be give or
her to be given the day off and given
something typically uh lift tickets
maybe for you and your family you and
your friends that's worth more than the
pay that that you didn't get
um so you get to be skiing you get to
have a day off uh you get some
compensation what's not to like it works
out for the employers
too so that is all the existing law none
of that this bill
changes what this bill does change is
that the Department of Labor found the
very
occasional and uh I I won't
I seem to remember one or two I may be
misremembering that um Town employees or
maybe County employees have contacted
the Department of Labor and said it says
here I get lift
tickets know where where is that and it
if you through this in terms of the
history of the how the law was written
uh the intent of the law that doesn't
make any sense but if you just read the
text as it's currently in the RSA yes
you can get that that the exception for
um employees of counties or
municipalities includes other
compensation that is at least equal to
the rate of pay uh so what this language
does is clearly separates those two
Clauses makes it clear that there's one
exception Municipal and County there's a
second exception that's different um for
snow Bo and ski
instructors otherwise it doesn't change
things at
all one last point I said there was an
issue with that and
um Mr berky I don't he I see he didn't
sign up to testify but he might be
available for questions contacted me and
said I see you're expanding our uh
exception that's great but I don't know
why you did that and I said
I didn't and then between some
discussions uh we we brought in uh
Deputy Commissioner Ogden and sure
enough there is a subtle difference in
if for those of you that are looking at
your copy of the bill between the
language that struck and the language
that's added back in the word instructor
was left out and
so not my intention at all not what I
want to do with this bill it could be
interpreted as changing the scope to
which this
applies um and so I would now having
this brought to my
intention um during the executive SE
session I would propose an amendment
that makes sure that that instructor
that comes
between uh it's actually instructional
snowboard instructional
employees um that instructional should
be inserted in the new language between
snowboard and employees as
well um and that I believe would
keep effect of the RSA exactly as it is
today but
clarify uh the legislative intent to be
what I think we all understand it as and
what how the department interprets it
thank you representative seart we have
any questions for
representative
I don't see any on my screen are there
any questions in the committee room Mr
Sullivan none but okay I'm told to Mr
Sullivan
unmute got it um I I I raised my hand
before representative seaworth um uh
indicated the his intent to amend and I
guess I would just uh say this is u i
I'm comfortable with the amendment that
M representative seaworth has proposed
and I would strongly urge that to uh
move
forward I do have a
question I gu that's not a question
sorry fine I do have a question just for
the committee as a whole I did receive
an email last night Brian seor I'm not
sure if it from you or from um from Mr
berky um about this am I the only one
that received that or did everyone has
received that and that
if I may clarify that came um it was
between you and I uh commissioner Ogden
and Mr berky and trying to clarify all
recognizing this missing word want to
make sure I didn't know who who had
received it any other questions in the
Callum
I can't hear we can't hear the audio in
the commit room if you would move to a
microphone that would be
great can you explain can you hear me
now
better I I'll repeat the question too
if okay if there's an issue can you
explain why there would be an exception
for
County and
municipality
and what a likely exception would be so
the question is can I explain why there
is an exception and what that exception
might apply to and um I would say let's
re when uh commissioner
Ogden is testifying because he will have
a better answer than I do
as to the why as I said during my
testimony I believe it's a 28a issue
that if we place a mandate on the towns
on the
counties uh which cost them money the
Constitution requires that the state Al
fund that cost and I I this actually if
you look at the timing this came in
right after that Amendment the people
passed that Amendment to the
Constitution so I'm imagining that the
legislature was very aware of of
possible violations and that's how it
came in as far as uh when this could
happen we honestly
didn't get into that in detail because
again the the focus of that this is not
to revisit that policy as much as
clarify the language to mat the policy
in my own head I imagine things like
um a snowplow crew that gets notified
well there's going to be a big storm
tonight you guys have to be in we're
going to plow all night and then it
doesn't snow and and you might never be
required to do any work that would seem
to be the kind of thing where where this
might apply the other thing that I'll
imagine is it's it's an exception to the
requirement but it doesn't mean that
every town or every County actually uses
it so I would imagine um that many
employees who are under a contract that
contract might specify how this is done
um other towns or counties may as of a
matter of policy say even though we're
exempt from this law we follow it so
again uh commissioner Ogden May
practical answer those are my thoughts
thank you thank you questions on
Zoom any hands maybe I turn my
microphone on again do I see any
additional hands um via
to Ogden to testify on behalf of the
bill hi thank you chairman uh Rudy Ogden
for the Department of Labor just to Echo
uh the what was put forth by
representative seaworth uh this is a
bill that since its passage in
2016 um we had had some concerns at the
department again just not knowing uh how
we would look to say that Folks at the
counties or municipalities were going to
get uh you know additional or
alternative compensation so it's just
been something that we have um since
2016 looked at as a potential concern um
not understanding fully how we would
apply it in terms of the questions that
were just asked uh representative
seaworth um I think spoke to it quite
well that when this would come up it
would be exactly those instances in
which someone's asked to report to work
when they report to work they are then
told okay go home um and they've uh been
there for less than two hours um his
point is also a good one that many
counties and municipalities their
employees do operate under collectively
bargained agreements and those
collectively bargained agreements at
times speak to show up pay or other such
protections um so again I'm happy to
take any questions uh but in general the
department with uh the amendment that
representative seaworth uh discussed uh
we would look at this as a way of
clarifying um some confusion that's been
put into the law thank
you thank you uh any questions of the
assistant commissioner I see none here
in the hearing room I don't don't see
online that being said I have um two
people that have signed
in representa Tom
pla he uh is in
support and Tonda
gretzinger is
opposed see no other questions comments
or
speakers I'm going to close the hearing
on House Bill
303 and we have two or three minutes um
before I open the next hearing you do
have a hand up in attendees um chairman
um Bruce Burke has his hand
up in a lot of states he then I'm going
to I guess reopen the hearing and call
on rep uh Mr
berky thank you Mr thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee I sorry for
the late uh raising of the hand um I do
represent ski New Hampshire and and I
just wanted to clarify that we are in
support of House Bill 303 and we are in
support of the bill with uh the proposed
amendment that representative seaworth
and uh commissioner Ogden have have uh
brought before you today so I just you
know because I wasn't listed at the end
there when the chairman uh indicated who
was for and against it I just wanted to
clarify that for you that um we are in
speaker seeing none thank you very
much if there's no other individuals in
the queue hands up then we close the
hearing on
303 and uh keeping with uh the schedule
I wait two minutes just we open it on
time in case there's people not on
minutes
while we have a minute here do we have
any questions of the chair on any
anyone online um if you're still
listening if there's anything about
procedural uh Ben did I see your hand
up Ben Broody representative
Broody not you're on you're on mute I
think you're on mute I think okay yeah
thank you Mr chairman um the
representative mentioned a couple of
things um one is written testimony um
course this is all new to everybody here
how do we get a copy of the written
testimony or any handouts that anybody
might bring I know during the year I'm
sure we're going to get some brochures
or
whatever um if we're still doing this
remotely how are we going to get those
will they be mailed to us
or my um I I have to have another
conversation with um uh our assistant
Heather goalie but I do have U some
information that's provided by the
Department of Employment Securities that
P on to Heather pass on to everybody
else I figured it's best that that goes
through our assistant now maybe I'm
going to be told that that's not correct
but the goal is to have written
testimony being presented prior to
hearing about a half an hour before the
hearing I received these sheets here
these are all the individuals that have
um logged in and said there would either
like to speak and if they would not like
to speak whether they're in favor or
against uh and so far this worked pretty
well I have a good list on every single
Le bill um I am not aware of any written
testimony uh but again these are some of
the more simple bills that we have today
as we get into think a little more uh
involved legislation in the next two or
three meetings um hopefully people will
present them and they will be emailed to
everyone but I will confirm that for you
at the lunch break uh representative
buuy and uh get back to the committee
okay thank you Mr chairman welcome any
other question questions of the chair
from the committee members on anything
such so what do you think so far
guys not the way I like it call me an
old traditionalist like it's the old
fashioned way but I want to make's
comfortable it seems to
work
I'm sorry was there another comment from
the uh folks on Zoom yeah I did I just
thank I'll be talking with her
afterwards to see whether or not like in
the next meeting with my laptop here
I'll be able to exactly what she
do um as they run short on possible uh
Personnel that we would be able to
manage it to the the best
see I said I went online a couple nights
ago and I there's a lot of people on um
YouTube how to use this and I most very
the rudimentary stuff I didn't see
anything that explains to me how behind
the scenes to to know how to move
someone from participant to whatever and
on well quite frankly I was on a uh I
was in front of the um lonia Town
Council earlier in the week and so I got
to see it from a
standpoint of me being the member of the
public speaking on but apparently my
computer has not the the best upgrade
that I need to the newest Zoom so I they
weren't able to hear me so that
individual knew the moderator knew that
I needed the newest Zoom thing and said
well I have to move him this gentleman
to a participant so he can speak was all
the seene which isn't necessarily what
we want to do because you don't want
anyone to do anything unsightly in the
background is learning all the different
um that are it's quite me when you take
down the layers of all different things
in Zoom it is kind of cool what they
developed give credit for
that right it is 10 o' on the Node CL
walked out of the room
so I'm going to wait a second
um sorry we're going to wait one more
minute you went to get some water or
fine okay I am going to open the hearing
on House Bill 301 relative to
compensation appeals board and I
recognize representative seor
introduces thank you Mr chairman and
again apologies for not getting my uh my
sign up done
correctly um thank you to the committee
for uh hearing this bill this is
a another bill uh a set of language
that's associated with that labor
statute study committee in this case as
I said we narrowed the focus of um the
rsas that we looked at in this that
committee and the Department of Labor
provided us a number of other issues
that they' identified but were outside
our scope um so we accepted that
language but we didn't really discuss it
and this is one of those where the
department um forwarded some suggested
language to improve in
RSA
um but it was outside the scope of the
committee so I have simply submited
their
suggestion uh as a bill in this case
it's very simple what it
does
um it this applies to the attorney
members of the compensation appeals
board right now the
language um identifies a perdum rate
for when they're working the change
language would clarify that when they're
at hearings and they're taking a whole
day they get paid the perum rate if
they're doing other work that doesn't
take a whole day then the per DM is
pro-rated to an hourly rate and they get
paid only for the work that they've done
again I don't believe and I don't
believe the department believes this is
a policy change um rather
it's
uh getting specific about a possible
ambiguity in the way a
perum might be applied if you are not
working a whole
questions here I'm going to go with
representative
and then representative suan
representative thank you Mr chairman
than I think I think I see Mr Ward's uh
hand
first
thank my question becomes if we're going
to be prating for
how thank you representative for your
question that is an excellent question
that I don't have the full answer to
because I imagine that
um a day of hearings is not a a clock in
clock out 8 hour work day um so I would
ask that you save that question for
commissioner Ogden and get some
clarification from him we'll do
representative I think I've got a s
similar question so um but I I'll I'll
state it and then maybe also reserve it
for um um the Deputy Commissioner but um
the way I read this it sounds like if an
attorney um goes to a hearing regardless
of if it's a quarter day half
day or full day they get their um
prum because it's the new language
refers to other related work not the
hearings so um I guess my question is
whether or not um a an attorney would be
paid a full PDM anytime he or she
attended a
hearing thank you representative for
your question and yes I read the
language as you've just described and
again I I the key point to me is I don't
believe this change is
intended to uh change our current policy
so the way it works under the existing
language
is um if you're assigned to and attend
hearings you get paid the perdum rate
for the day that you go to hearings and
it it doesn't matter how many hearings
you hear or or whether that takes part
of a day or an entire day so yes I my
understanding of the change language is
it would preserve that policy for
hearings um and only apply the pr rating
to other work thank
you right representative Warden thank
you representative seaworth is this
pration based on an8 hour day so that
for example if the attorneys get $400
per DM if they're doing work outside of
a hearing it'd be divide by eight and
hour thank you representative for the
question and um until the questions
start coming I I would have thought well
yes of course that would be how to
interpret it but now that I think about
it I realize that is up for uh
interpretation so
once again I uh encourage you to Reas
your question to commissioner Ogden when
he
testifies are there any other questions
Zoom I don't see any except someone has
a white piece of paper up I don't know
if that's a message to me or
not sorry that was representative
sorry on camera okay I see no other
questions online I have any other
questions for represent cworth in the in
the hearing
room seeing none thank you
representative seaward I call um Rudy
Ogden from the Department of
Labor thank you chairman infantine um in
terms of context for this just one thing
I would point out the compensation
appeals board is a separate and distinct
board from the Department of Labor they
are administratively attached to the
Department of Labor and what that means
is we provide certain administrative
support namely and perhaps most
importantly the processing of pay so the
Genesis of this request or the Genesis
of this cleanup was this was actually
something that was looked at by the LBA
some time ago uh the compensation
appeals board has been in place for over
30 years and for 30 years the way that
those uh individuals have been paid is
that if they come in and do a hearing
they get the full per DM rate if they
are reading uh looking at a medical
packet if they're writing a decision if
they're talking amongst the members
because these boards are all three they
hold uh hearings in three panel boards
three member panels excuse me um but if
they're doing any of that other work uh
what they would do is they would take
the the full per DM rate and they would
divide by eight and say okay this is an
hourly rate and then what they would do
is submit that to the department and
that is how the department has processed
um pay to the compensation appeals board
members again going back to I believe
1990 or
1991 it's some time ago so this was
something that the LBA had pointed out
and said relative to the processing of
this payroll you should probably look at
having the statute adjusted um so I
don't know if that answers all of the
questions but essentially what the
thought is is to again not change the
way that any of these folks are actually
getting paid is to just have the statute
reflect the fact that this is how these
individuals turn their time in they turn
it in and they'll say okay it was a
hearing day or they'll turn it in and
they'll say um you know I worked on a
decision for two hours or I reviewed
medical packets for two hours or things
nature thank you Mr Ogden representative
turkot does that answer your question
actually
would like to speak to it thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh Deputy
Commissioner um you did answer the
question but as we're Mak an attempt to
change and clarify language now I think
it would be possibly a great opportunity
to clarify it into the RSA rather than
leaving it as an administrative rule
behind the scenes would you be opposed
to when this comes back for exe
executive session
um clarifying it a little bit better
down to what your hourly
rate actually
is no we would be happy to consider any
of those I will say that the language
surrounding this largely results from
discussions or findings we had seen from
the LBA so if there's a way to even
improve upon that and make it clearer
for everyone we would uh be in full
support of
that representative Sullivan did that
answer your previous question
I'm I'm fine thank you representative
Warden thank you another thing that
comes up is what if they work more than
eight hours in a day is it still
pro-rated they could earn more than they
would have for the standard uh per DM
for
example um in practice I believe for
that other prated work I don't know that
we've ever seen someone put in more than
eight hours uh to your point I imagine
then that that would be able to they
would just be getting that rate for more
than eight hours but I will be honest in
that any other questions on Zoom
representative kahill I see yes thank
you Mr chairman and thank you uh Deputy
ogon uh should we add the the eight hour
as the as the standard and the basis of
the
pum to uh my earlier response to
representative turot if if if it's found
to be clear to you whatever is is I I
think the best product if that clarifies
any confusion that folks have I think
that would be worthwhile yes thank
you any other
online any other questions or
representatives in the L
here seeing
none uh Christine are there any other
individuals with their hands raised that
would like to speak on behalf
of I don't see
anyone
okay in addition to the two individuals
that
spoke again uh Eric rfam a member of the
public does support the bill
representative Tom
plza uh does support the bill as
well
seeing no other questions or comments
regarding House Bill 301 and close the
hearing and House Bill 301 we will next
a.m.
comment I heard someone asking something
of me all right folks we're going to
take a little break sorry I I left a
space here in case we were
behind thank you and ril return uh at
11: a.m. up till
you
o and just remember they never turn off
the Camas and
microp anything in here everybody's
watching on anything you wouldn't say to
your mother
[Music]
here
all
o00
[Music]
right
e
boyy
for
you
online
[Applause]
back
you know I
name
for
that
in
[Music]
for
other one's CED so I don't know what to
one
sorry I got caught off I was trying to
water a plant and there was noise in the
background
um okay so I will you know tell every
one that that's the best way to do it is
to make sure that they get all you know
when I did log on I didn't even look to
mechanism
yep all right thank
you well I did one I did one but the one
the cactus the tall Cactus what do you
water
oh I don't know I just give it some
water we'll
see and I'll just give a little bit to
the C
thanks
for
e hey Josh yeah have you signed online
yet to
testify on any other
bill cuz I'm trying to figure out
whether you can submit I was just
talking to Heather our assistant to
figure out how to do the written
testimony she talked about everyone
really needs to go on the website and
hit all and send an email to all of the
Reps to get us the written testimony
that way it'll also get to the clerk um
but she asked she hadn't logged on
either and I have but I didn't look to
see so yeah I haven't submitted anything
yet so you when you I don't know whether
when you sign up this list I'm getting
here you know whether or not you can
submit WR testimony through through that
mechanism where you have to just do it
all
you the designated driver
lot yeah know it works but I'm not there
mentally I read something recently where
something like uh 75% of communication
is
Visual and while this is better than a
conference
call um the technology is pretty damn
good give it that but it just
not yeah no it's it's better to focus on
stuff when you're
actually
there yeah we I picked the really simple
ones today that I knew would be just a
very few people testifying we can kind
of get this under our belt but if if
you're in finance and if you're in some
ways and means or maybe I guess they had
a really big Bill and just yesterday was
a marijuana thing and there's so many
moving parts to some of these cars are
simple usually cleanups are the one
simple part of a piece of legislation uh
some of these other committies Commerce
they got 46 bills we have
16 um I you know tough and up yeah I've
been around here couple times when
Commerce had so much going on they
separated their their committee you know
they took half a committee in one room
and half a committee in the other room
to hear enough
bills um so I I've always thought like
they have fin
division one and two that they either
need to find a way to Sugar off some
bills cuz sometimes they get some of our
bills that we really should have here in
Labor uh or they just have to have
Commerce one and commerce 2 you
know it's not like we can't sacrifice
another 20 members take one off each
committee
right I think it it prudes some people
cuz some people get burnt out being on
that committee for more than a couple
sorry I know you're working on J sorry
sure
[Music]
you see where these kids uh you know
fourth graders they learn about the
state house and they usually bring them
up here for a tour and it gets a little
foolish after a while you know some
teachers think hey we should have a
piece of legislation we should submit
it's always you know the state with the
state dist you see that the one
yesterday the state
ARA the state spider oh yeah I saw that
are they doing like state house visits
later in the year or they doing them
like I hope so virtually or I don't know
what they're doing I really would you
know I remember I was in back then and I
I did the tour of here you know and I
remember that um cuz we got lost in the
tunnel we
know we were on but um I hope
that you know obviously all field trips
are
probably Kash right now but I'm really
hoping come April or May possibly you
know if enough of our population is
vaccinated uh that they can
feel if they're going to go back to live
in school again that they can feel
comfortable coming up here even if the
Public's not here and it's just all the
representatives
um but you know we'll see you know what
are they when middle of marks they're
hoping to have everyone 65 and
over and the mark state by state I um no
at least yeah here
yeah so if we can get everyone over 65
and
older by the end of March you start
getting into 50 olders April and May
yeah I know I know the only state so far
that's gotten their nursing home
population done has been West Virginia
but they didn't sign that CBS walens AG
oh so yeah I always thought that you
know yeah well like nursing home
residents are sedentary they're not
going anywhere show up at the nursing
home and start stabbing folks
you don't need to shill it
out Walgreens to keep track of
it agreed since they already have their
anyway yeah there's some things that I
differently but I mean we like I think
we lost it was some awful number like a
fifth of the residents at the uh
veterans
home so you what T me the most about the
whole
thing my my father-in-law is in a
nursing home right
now and um he's had his he did get it he
survived and he's had his now his two
shots but we couldn't see
him you know when they shut stuff down
in March we haven't been able to see him
we had a couple visits in the summer we
could go outside 10 ft away in the tent
we all had that m whatever uh her
birthday in November he was in the other
side of a glass sliding glass door and
and what have you so what irritates me
is that those people in the nursing
home got Co they got it from the staff
yeah and I don't know maybe I'm an old
fashioned but Jesus Louise how come they
want better protocols on this
staff I mean you know all these people
that died and
it wasn't because of their family
members bringing it to
them
the you know come on maybe they should
have been more careful maybe you know I
don't know maybe they had to get tested
on their day off you know on on a
Saturday so they come back on I don't
know I don't know what you could have
done yeah the delayed response to
testing is a pain in the neck especially
with a disease like Co where there's a
delay in having it and knowing you have
it right and and not knowing you have't
still
being there the big frustration for me
was that there were so many flagrantly
contradictory um federal and state
orders surrounding you know taking time
off if you feel sick and before Co like
I've been in situations where I felt
like absolutely garbage and still have
to go work because you know it's a
different economy nowadays you have to
make that money and and you know some
folks might just think they have the
cold or something and it turns out it's
coron
virus now it's it's you
know it's easy to be Monday Morning
Quarterback yeah but you know there's
going to be a lot of a lot of sad
Lessons Learned for this whole thing
say I I fortunately not
known anyone
personally that died some friends that
had some friends and relatives but I
died but I tremendous amount of friends
and relatives that contracted so far
they were
okay both my daughters in college but
um you know you see some of these
stories where you know that one case in
Texas like six members of
family well there was that 41y old
congressman from Louisiana died I
think Larry King died like a month after
he got it so the 2 we you know
incubation period isn't always accurate
but he was also 87 years old so true but
you know that 41y old congressman and
um
for
will I did mute them for the time being
oh oh is
that
okay
think I got lucky I got stuffed in
y I avoided that if everyone's going to
get ready we're going to start the uh
hearing on house Bill 258 in about 5
minutes
please representative Sullivan can you
hear
me oh I broke my math number one
I
that
know
that's look at
that
s
for
is everybody getting back to to their
computers we have uh two minutes um I
did speak with Heather Gully during the
break about uh written testimony and at
this point it is recommended that
individuals that would like to submit
written T testimony go on to the website
and go to the labor
committee page and then email all
there's a section there to email every
um every representative that's the best
way for that to happen um I do not know
if there's a portal um there's a
mechanism to do it um Christina I don't
know if you can answer this question if
someone were to log on to um sign up to
testify or to uh log in whether they
support or do not support is there a
mechanism when you sign up to testify on
a bill in Zoom to uh provide written
testimony um an email is you get to the
end of the option and it provides an
email for you and it is the all
committee labor email um so you can
either find that um during the test the
remote sign in testimony on the very
last page or you can go on understanding
committees and find it
there okay I hope that answers
everyone's questions uh anyone uh feel
free we got a minute here two minutes uh
if anyone wants to speak freely they
that I have to bring my gavel from a
couple years ago I saved it
so 11 o'clock I'm going to open the
hearing on House Bill 258 relative to
employee time cards time records and I
will introduce the sponsor if he is on
representative Josh yo Kella
representative yeah thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh committee for
hearing another one of my bills today
I uh just sent you uh an email to the to
the um to the whole whole committee um
which I may be referencing throughout
this um so the goal of this legislation
is stemming from um the labor regulation
8033 um F2 which
requires that time records with entries
that are altered shall be signed or
initialed by the employee whose record
was altered um this requirement stems
from um RSA
27927 and RSA
27549 uh Roman numo rule
six um the so I when I requested this
bill to be drafted that was the stated
goal is to allow my the stated goal was
to allow for
electronic um records to
be um allowed for the acknowledgement or
signing off of changes to one's time
sheet especially in
uh this time of so many people working
remotely uh changes to time
sheets actually signing a piece of paper
is not always uh
appropriate in uh you know not everyone
necessarily has a printer at home or
whatever to print this the document out
and sign it
um
I've talked with the labor department
and they said that people are actually
already doing this um some people are
are signing or keeping electronic
records um but it isn't technically
allowed in the law it's kind of just
based on what is your definition of
signed or initialed um is an electronic
signature or initial um appropriate and
so I wanted to just clarify that in the
in the um
statute however I'm not sure that the
recommended way
from uh OS is the best way um as I as
the um language that is
proposed is to add another section to
RSA
um Roman numeral 8 that doesn't really
address the I doesn't really address the
issues of Roman numeral
um six or the are RSA that I mentioned
um and if you look at the the um
RSA um 27
27549 um at the very the very
first uh language is every employer
shall and so adding
another adding a Roman numeral eight
just adds uh a requirement that the
employer
shall uh do what we are do the
proposed
um solution which is to permit an
employee to electronically sign or
acknowledge alterations to such
employees wages or our records um
requiring uh an employer to allow them
to do that makes them require them to
have that technology and not necessarily
every um uh employer will have that
technology and
so I think that this is not the
appropriate way to fix the bill or not
the appropriate way to address the issue
but I have sent a couple of suggestions
to the uh committee via email of how
this language might be amended
to uh to change to make the desired
effect actually be instantiated into law
um and that is to actually change those
two either one or both of those um
sections that the labor department is
referencing when requiring s signature
or uh
initials and I am sure that the uh the
labor
department uh in communication with them
they seem to already be okay with this
issue um and and recognize that it's
already happening and so it's just
um an effort to make it more clear in
the law and to get
um where I think that we should need to
be so that it's clear to people that
they are allowed to sign electronically
or keep the records
electronically um thank you Mr Speaker
or Mr uh chairman and I'm happy to take
any
questions all right thank you
representative um looking for questions
I see none in the committee room my
glasses are fogging up because of my MK
I don't any online so the chairman has a
um representative uh when you make a law
that says you
shall you have to think about everybody
on either the most sophisticated
companies to the least sophisticated
companies would it be more appropriate
to allow a May situation here they may
allow electronic
signature
um that way a company can do it if they
have a technology if they don't but by
Sha
answer to that if you could would you
accept a May versus a shall yes thank
you thank you um Mr chairman for the
question that's actually um exactly my
point of why I don't really like the
language as currently written um as I
look deeper into the
RSA it could be changed to a a sh but I
think that um um that
would that would change kind of the
whole uh RSA whereas it might just be
better to be clarified that paper or
electronic records are what shall be
kept and not say that you have to do one
or the other just have that option
open I have one more question for you
representative um you talk about um
alter to employees wage and hour records
what does that mean to you would that be
uh as simple as emailing someone
regarding a change to some kind of an
electronic or written time card or would
that also include someone receiving a
raise uh and an email s they could send
an email uh we're you know giving you a
$3 an hour raise starting you know
February 1st and they could acknowledge
that in writing are
you are you thinking about all of these
things or was this specifically to
just like a weekly or or hourly time
card thank thank you for the question
yes
um
this this bill directly addresses only
manipulations of the time clock um so if
you forgot to clock in or you had a PTO
and so there is no clock in and so they
had to change your record
um uh those
manipulations are what is changing
because there are
other parts of the
um
notification uh and payment of wages and
changing of people's
uh uh hourly rate or different sections
in um RSA 27549 that deal with that and
while I think that all of them should be
allowed to be done electronically
or um via paper I think that uh it's
more reasonable for you know a one-time
change of someone's you pay of you know
50 cents raise or whatever would be more
understandable to be required to be
paper where whereas
um someone you know every week you know
forgetting to clock in or clock out or
having PTO it the in the massive amount
of paperwork that that requires of
changing um on a routine basis
um seems to me to be uh have a bigger
impact on the employers and so that
would be I think the most important
thing to address
where but I'm not opposed to um allowing
all records to be to be kept and
acknowledged uh digitally thank you
question represent
ad thank you Mr chairman um so I'm
looking at um the structure of this say
it's written it looks like um
12 is more closely
aligned uh with line three um when you
signed off on this what was the logic by
having that and after RSA
27537 because it looks like you could
divorce that shell um that's on line n
own
representative did you hear the question
yes I I don't have um the the uh paper
copy that he is
referencing in front of me I'm looking
at the actual
um the actual law online and so at the
very top of RSA uh
27549 it
before all of the room and numerals it
says every employer
shall um do these things and so I think
uh it I was only really looking at the
bill um and
as and not really looking at the whole
RSA as it worked together um and so I
didn't see all of the sections of this
um
27549 and so I didn't think that it was
necessary to uh correct OS when they
they suggested this language as to meet
my request so now that I'm looking at
the whole RSA I think that it could
be the language could be improved to not
require every employee to or employer to
have this technology and um I think it
could just be worded better so I'm happy
to uh propose an amendment to this bill
or in whichever way that the um the
committee or the committee could amend
it
to reach the goal that I I tried to
achieve with this bill representative um
yo yo K just just hold on a moment I
think represent wants to
um explain him himself go ahead
representative uh thank you uh well and
just the only reason like I'm asking
about this I'm looking at where the word
shall comes in and it's in what appears
to be a completely unrelated thing to
what's being um proposed as an addiction
to the RSA the word shall is referenced
in the it's illegal in the state of
Hampshire uh under both state and
federal law to employes different wages
for the same work based solely on sex uh
this notice shall also include the
address phone number and email of email
address Department Personnel to be
contacted with complaints under the
subdivision as well as the internet link
to RSA
27537 so that just looks like you know
in an employ break room um just letting
folks know that if you think that you
know a lady is making less in the office
then um this is who you contact so
that's with the word shall in that the
debate revolves around and then there's
an and after RSA
27537 and then it goes into something
completely unrelated what I'm suggesting
for an amendment to clarify is if you
strike the word end as was done in line
five um right before it goes into Roman
numeral 7 and then you you know
permitted employee to electronically
sign or acknowledge alterations du
employees waiter hours records now
that's a completely different thing and
you don't have you know the link to the
last section would you believe you
believe thank you thank you for the
clarification of your question um I
think you're you
are interpreting the language based on
the um the the text of the bill in in
kind of how I was um and not really
looking at the whole RSA if you pull up
the whole RSA to
7549 at the very very top before all the
room and numerals there's an employer
shall so it actually the employer shall
do all of the Roman
numerals is the issue that I am coming
up against and that is not in the text
of the bill and so it was not possible
to really seen unless I went and go went
and looked at the entire RSA and I and
the only reason why seven is listed in
there is because they made that an they
move the an from six to seven Roman
numeral six to rumin numeral 7 um I
don't think that the uh the notice shall
include um also the address and anything
all that the rest of that line is is the
sh that I'm talking about that would
require employees to
electronically um to
allow uh employees to electronically
sign or alteration so I think that's
actually not the correct um place to
amend this but I'm I'm happy that that
the uh representative is is um willing
to to work with me on this any other
questions for the representative FAL
bage bill online anyone I don't see any
hands representative um appreciate
representative avalani has his hand up
okay I didn't see that representative
avalone
your thank you Mr chairman um a question
of you actually could we put in an
exception Clause after the first line
and then reference the time to either
being manual or
actions representative y yell Oh I
thought it was a question of the the
chair but um I do believe that uh an
amendment to Roman numeral 6 um to say
to add some clarification to that would
be uh a valid amendment to to reach this
goal
absolutely
I don't see any other hands raised uh
representative um I would ask that you
know politely it's not the
responsibility of the the committee
um to to amend things this is your bill
if you'd like to work with one of the
members of the committee to amend it we
would accept any amendments to your bill
I representative Al may have
a representative avalone on our screen
we still have your yellow hand up do you
have another question of the presenter I
I have a followup um it's actually for
you Mr chairman um just for process
could we add in an exception and then
reference the time cards um because I
know every employee shall is the first
first sentence in the reference RSA um
I'm just wondering if we could put in an
exception and then and then list the
time card issue specifically as an
exception and then have it be made um
either uh manually or
electronically you representative um
having not looked at the entire RSA I
don't know if that would run a file of
any other part so I I really feel
uncomfortable answering that question it
would have to something to go to OS um
to make that determination I'm sorry I
can't be more specific but I I have not
studied the rest of the the
you
Sullivan you're
mute representative Sullivan did it
again sorry um I I was just wanting to
make a suggestion to the chair that
perhaps um a member of the committee
would want to volunteer to work with um
the sponsor to come up with a it's
awkward getting a bill that's um being
presented as uh not ready for um uh
prime time um but I think it's a noble
issue um and perhaps uh one of the me
members of the committee would want to
work with the sponsor to uh make it
time any member of the
committee is is welcome to do so um if
you you're willing to I would appreciate
if you would uh contact by email um the
the
sponsor
um reprentative
you
offer offer an
amendment no I was just well we were
talking about like clarifying the
language and um I just saw that as the
um bigger issue but um I would have to
agree with the chairman that I'm not as
familiar with this particular RSA as I
wish I was um
so the represent might be correct far as
the structure might I don't know
so thank you representative Edison um uh
representative um yella obviously there
needs to be some changes here and the
bill is not ready for prime time I guess
as they say so I would appreciate if you
would reach out to any members of the
committee that you know or feel
comfortable with or even just email to
ask for a volunteer they may be able to
help you with this um
we are on a tight schedule and so it
would be something have to be done and
presented to us in the next week or
two any other
questions um uh in the form of amendment
excuse me any other questions online I
don't see any in the uh committee room I
don't see any so that being said thank
you very
much thank you your
testimony I'd like to uh now introduce
uh Ry
Ogden Deputy Commissioner of the
Department of
Labor
Commissioner sorry I was uh muted uh yes
just for the record Rudy Ogden
Department of Labor as representative
yaka yakola stated um this is currently
allowable under law um employers are we
don't have a requirement that it be done
in hard copy or we do not have a
Prohibition uh against it being done
electronically just given the discussion
one thing that I would point out is
perhaps uh something to look at is it
might be cleaner uh to address this type
of change under RSA
27927 um as representative Yak yaka
stated um their recordkeeping
requirements come from two places
27549 and
27927 27927 is the law that specifically
says that an employer has to have true
and accurate records um I just think
that that paragraph I defer of course to
OS and and in you folks in terms of Bill
writing um but I think that paragraph
might be more malleable I think that it
might be better suited for making this
type of change so I just offer that up
as a potential idea but most importantly
the department this is already allowable
so we don't have concerns and if there
is an intent to clarify the law I think
thing thank you Mr Ogden any questions
uh any folks online any yellow handm
up I see none in the committee oh sorry
right in the committee
um I don't know why I have a brain cramp
of having to say your name
representative ad
adant sorry um if and thank you Mr a um
if the Department of Labor uh still
considers the intention of this bill
already
Miss
um what what what is the cleanup that
this is trying to
accomplish uh it's a good question
representative in terms of cleanup as I
referenced a moment ago RSA
27927 essentially says that employers
are supposed to have true and accurate
records through regulation we've tried
to flesh out what are true and accurate
records and it is in regulation that we
discuss this idea of uh a initialing um
the or signing off on alterations to
Time Records so I think that elevating
something that's in regulation to
statute sometimes is of benefit because
regulations as you know are typically
pushed or promulgated through the
department uh signed off of course by
jail car and ultimately the legislature
as a whole but I think if there is
opportunities to bring stuff that
departments are doing in regulation and
bring that up to statute so that the
representatives can debate it and see it
do all of those things I do think that
at time there's a benefit to that so
that's why I would point it out as a
potential
benefit
okay are further questions in the
hearing
online Christina are there any other
individuals wishing to
speak looks uh looks like representative
Tumi has his hand
up thank
[Music]
you yeah I I'm not sure I if I see why
this is needed uh I'll give you an
example uh the last place that I worked
we had a system where we punched in and
we punched out
electronically and we kept track of
where each of us was because you know we
had to work into actively so if we won
an assignment we we went and pressed the
button said that you know I'm on
assignment and then we pressed the
button when we got back and and said we
were back sometimes you know we forgot
to say we were back sometimes I would
punch
out uh forget the punch out at night and
uh what I would do was call the
administrative assistant and say I
forgot to punch out last night and she
took care of the amount of hours I
worked on that given day uh
what are we trying to accomplish here
why wouldn't people be able to say Hey
listen I didn't punch out or or I didn't
uh record you
know my uh unpaid uh times off or
whatever like that why is this necessary
I I just don't understand it or if you
could make that clarify that for me
thank you um thank you representative
Tumi in terms of the purpose of this
again the from a statutory basis there's
a requirement that employers have true
and accurate records when we've tried to
flesh out what that means at through
regulation in
80303 F what we've said is that if you
have alterations to Time Records they
should be acknowledged or initialed by
employees now the the example you gave I
think that that is what happens all
across the state every day where you run
into problems however is there have been
occasions where we've received reced
calls from employees saying hey I worked
42 hours last week and my time uh my
payroll my paycheck suggests that I
worked 38 in certain scenarios when we
followed up on those inspections what
we've seen is that the person's punching
in day in and day out punching out for
lunch breaks all of that stuff but at
the end of the week there might be a
unilateral adjustment to time just the
employer going in and saying okay I'm
I'm moving the time down down um the
example you gave again the employees
prompting it and the employers
correcting it so that is good um where
we're looking for the acknowledgement is
just so that we don't have these
unilateral adjustments because in
certain instances that's led to time uh
in which has not been reflective or
Mr
Prout see that representative
pro thank you Mr chairman so it kind of
seems like the Crux of this problem is
the fact that the word you know
signature or initial is used in the
rules and that doesn't perfectly
translate over to a digital time card
where I think people would prefer to you
know track it as digital audit trail of
who made a change when which doesn't
perfectly map to the signature and
initial language in the rules so is the
real fix here to maybe work with the
department and uh change the rule to
acknowledge that digital audit records
might be viable in lie of signature and
initial and not try to get into the
debate of what a digital signature is
and would the department be open to that
change thank you representative it we we
would be open to look looking that I
would say and representative infantine
commented on this earlier a lot of times
it you have to consider there's a whole
uh array of employers out there and
payroll systems and timekeeping systems
and we do try and work with each
employer to understand their system and
and uh the capabilities of such we would
be open to of course looking at our rule
I mean if if we would be happy to
clarify our rule to say that uh you know
initialed or signed and and be clear
that that could be done electronically
but we're happy to work with anybody on
informative thank you thank you
representative any other
[Music]
questions Christina are there any other
individuals wishing to speak not at this
time all right thank you that being the
case I will uh announce that there were
two other individuals Eric
Ram uh
uh is supportive of this bill
representative Tom
plaza
plaza uh is in support as
well I will be I'll be closing the
bill House Bill 348 requiring a public
employer to provide notice of a new or
amended collective bargaining agreement
I recognize the sponsor representative
turot to introduce his
Bill thank you Mr chairman and uh
members of the committee much likee uh
representative seaworth I've removed
myself uh virtually and will present
this bill uh this bill come my name is
uh representative Glen turkot I
represent the District of uh uh straford
number four which encompasses the town
of barington uh this bill comes before
you it's on request of the uh president
of the School District Governor
governance Association and I believe uh
she has provided lengthy written
testimony on this bill uh before I get
into the bill itself just so everybody's
aware and uh prior to executing this
bill of course it'll be made available
but the original bill didn't quite
capture the true intent so the last
lines of this bill has been changed
slightly so I'm going to read that for
you and what it says now is both the
notice and the electronic copy of the
tenative agreement shall remain on the
public employers internet website for
not less than 30 days after reaching the
tenative
agreement and then it says no new or
amended collective bargaining agreement
shall be ratified by the public employer
until after the Internet Posting has
expired again that'll be made
available uh before I get into exactly
what the bill does I want to give you a
little background uh personal background
which I believe is very relative to this
bill I've been a member of the Allied
Pilots Association for 36 years and
that's a independent Union that
represents currently 14,500 Pilots uh of
American Airlines and during my time as
a union member
I have served at the national level for
almost uh nearly eight years of
full-time Union work uh in different
roles one as a h one of 16 board of
directors I was at the Boston base
chairman representing 550 Pilots based
in the New England area uh V various
National Committee chairs and most
relevant to this
discussion uh an elected member of the
the pilots negotiating uh committee
what HB 348 is about is adding a little
bit of transparency into the collective
bargaining process there are generally
two parties uh in the collective
bargaining agreement or that they that
the agreements ultimately impact those
being the taxpayers and the members of
the public sector unions themselves the
issue is that for the majority of these
situations the two part parties are at a
minimum one layer removed from the
negotiating process and are sometimes
provided little to no knowledge about
what went on in uh NE
negotiations until those agreements have
been uh signed now it is true that these
uh labor Agreements are eventually
posted on the labor relations website
but again that's after the
fact so what this bill would do would
provide both the union member and the
interested taxpayers the ability to
review a tenative agreement before it
became a collective bargain bargaining
agreement uh being ratified by the party
responsible and it would also give them
a little bit of time to provide input to
their respective authorizing bodies uh
for those unfamiliar with the process
typical negotiation process each side
designates individuals to negotiate the
tenative agreement that ta is in given a
thumbs up or down by the authorizing or
approving body and then once the TA is
ratified it does become a collective
bargaining
agreement so under this bill after the
TA tenative agreement is reached there'
be two
requirements uh that would apply and
this is key solely to the public
employer has places no burdens on the
unions this would be solely a uh burden
on the public employer the first of the
two
the first would require that the public
employer post on their website a notice
stating that a TA had been reached the
second requirement would mandate a
posting of the tenative agreement
itself both of these would need to
remain on the website for no less than
30 days before the approving bodies
could vote the tenative agreement up or
down now anticipating a couple possible
questions
I was mentioned earlier that what about
if the public employer does not have a
website I in this day and age I assume
that everybody would have a website at
this time but if if that's not the case
uh prior to executing the bill we could
also add language that would allow
posting on their bulletin boards or you
know
whatever was
needed
um I assume somebody is going to mention
that 30 days might be a long time to
wait and that that would delay the
process well the way I look at it as
being a negotiator if I know that 30
days is part of the
process I'm gonna use that and account
for that 30 days into my bargaining
process I would
also submit that in a way that could
cause the parties to actually get to
their agreement a little bit uh
earlier
um I believe that's what I have I thank
you Mr chairman then be happy to take
any
questions any questions hearing room we
have a panelist who has
rep
um so your experience with these kind of
negotiations um
has what is the average time that you've
seen between a agreement being reached
and the final
vot I can only speak to
my my personal history the way it works
at our our Union is when the two parties
come to a tenative agreement it goes
back in our case it'll come to our board
of directors then our board directors
actually takes it on I don't remember
the time frame it can be different but
anywhere from 15 to 30 days they
actually go on a road show to all the
crew bases in our case I think we've got
about 12 crew bases right now maybe 13
they do that then they go back the board
of directors votes on whether to send it
to the membership or the
ultimate uh you know vote give it gives
it the ultimate vote up or down so I
would say for us it's probably on
average 30 to can be even a little bit
longer um I think maybe a little bit of
a difference is uh in the railway Labor
Act with uh what we're part of of
contracts do not necessarily expire they
become amendable so it slight difference
there follow um so this would by default
acire a 30-day window in there opposed
to agreement
that's
correct I have a representative I
believe Tumi then
Sullivan and then Huff representative
Tumi that correct yeah thank you uh
thank you representative turot for your
testimony one question uh does this
apply to airline pilots this law will it
apply to airline
pilots
as written no this would reply this this
would apply to uh well I guess
technically it no because we're not a
public employer no okay thank you not
only that but for instance our our Union
America uh the Allied Pilots Association
is based out of Texas so I mean this is
a New Hampshire law it's not you know
this wouldn't apply to my particular
Union that's correct thank you thank you
representative
Sullivan thank you
um uh representative I recognize that
you've got a lot of experience uh with a
private sector Union um I've got 30
years of experience uh negotiating for
um public sector unions in New Hampshire
and um there are some issues that I that
uh I like you to uh address with regard
to the public sector um there are tight
timelines with regard to um uh the
public sector negotiations and there's
also a step that you didn't uh uh
include in your um testimony and that is
the um the approval of a uh collective
bargaining agreement by the legislative
body that would be a school district
meeting a town meeting or um uh
potentially a city council or
such um so that
and the um there are deadlines for
getting um the uh the cost items um
published and those those deadlines
require in an sb2 town where there's um
um vote by ballot um the deadlines are
um require
um parties to be done with their
negotiations effectively um by the first
first week in
January um and if you are dealing with
mediations or uh fact findings you have
to back everything up um earlier than
that um and then if you add in a 30-day
timeline for um posting the tenative
agreement um that backs it up that much
further uh negotiations typically begin
in the um at the start of a school year
for school districts and
um that leaves a very limited amount of
time already if you back it up another
30 days um you've really cramped the
process pretty seriously um in
addition um I don't want to be rude
representative have a question yes I
well I would like I I'm I'd like to
point these things out and ask the
sponsor to uh address these issues um
well let let me let me stop there and
I'll ask for a
followup
okay I really didn't he a question in
there so I'm not sure what what you want
I I I guess what I'm what I'm asking is
um how how do you feel how do you see um
public sector uh unions and U employers
dealing with the um the timelines that
are inflicted by this um this this Bill
thank you for the question I think I
addressed that in the testimony and I uh
anticipating a question similar to this
that was you just the two part parties
recognizing that there's a 30-day
requirement just going to have to build
that into your
timelines followup Mr
[Music]
chairman there's um my experience also
is that uh it takes a fair amount of
time to go from a final negotiating
session where you reach an agreement in
a point in time where there's an actual
written fully developed collective
bargaining tenative agreement um
available for the parties to um to sign
um typically at a ratification meeting
the document that's uh documents that
are used are simply the the the issues
that are have been changed or added to
the collective bargaining agreement um
if you're looking for a full tenative um
Collective baring agreement that might
take a a period of weeks as well um how
that I believe I would say the exact
same thing I just said last question
that would be you know the deadlines you
got you got
app thought process as you're doing your
negotiations I mean wouldn't be any
different if we if we set an artificial
deadline at aerica for the our Pilots or
somebody set an artificial deadline on
our we're going to have to take into
effect account the full process the
process doesn't end at a TA you know if
you've got 30 days to let the public
view then you've got to build that into
your process it's the same that we do at
for our Pilots we can't the day we uh
come to a tenative agreement we can't
have our board of directors go yep we
agree to it send it out to the
membership the next Daye there got to be
a a time period where the membership can
actually take a look at it that's what
this bill does it gives the ability of
the both not only just the the the
taxpayers but it gives the union members
actually a little bit of time to look at
it so again it's it's a process you know
the time and you got to address it
that's
all any additional followup
representor no I'm I'm dissatisfied but
uh understand
right representative Huff yes thank you
Mr chairman
um representative terot I've been
looking at this and I don't see it
saying anywhere
expressly that the 30-day is required to
be up before another portion of the
agreement
occurs so I'm just not I'm not
understanding why everybody is talking
about this back the process this just
simply says it has to be up for 30 days
has nothing to do am I right in what I'm
seeing here or you are partially right
um at the very beginning of my testimony
I read an amendment that clarifies it a
little bit more to what we're talking
about right now okay thank you and that
will you want I can read my copy since
you're right here thank you I see a hand
raised representative Susi is that
correct that's correct thank you Mr
chairman
uh thank you representative turot for
taking the question um I'm just
curious if that tenative agreement is
posted for 30
days and
the in the public sector unions in the
taxpayers um have the opportunity to
look at it do they have an opportunity
to try to make changes in those
don't
uh say did you say a question again rep
I'm just wondering if they the taxpayers
see the tenative agreement online um
they're not going to have any input in
um the outcome of that tenative
agreement
correct uh the way the bill is written
that's correct there it's there
specifically for the individuals to look
mean member I I believe you were former
requirement uh this applied to your
particular Union this
um your membership would have the
opportunity to look at it um it would
also give them the opportunity obviously
to give input to your negotiators or
your president of the association or
whoever um is that going to be enough to
influence a change U by the union that I
you I believe that's
repres
representative my list of everybody got
Nam to faces representative
buar thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
uh I I'm a little bit confused about why
you would want to make a tenative a
tenative agreement public
prior to it being agreed
upon by both parties because things can
question the whole idea of having a
30-day period is to provide transparency
and give both the
members and the again
ultimate responsible part from the
public the
taxpayers actual time to review what is
in the tenative agreement before it
becomes a certified Collective
barain followup follow representa uh
then why don't you put in your
bill the ratified agreement made
public because the uh thank you m thank
you Char the ratified collective
bargaining agreement is after it's
ratified it is put on the website the
labor relation Bo website today and look
now once it's it's a done deal this
gives the
opportunity
um first individual excuse me chairman
online is is that better much better
thank you sorry I'm trying to be
conscientious with my Mas we do have um
one person signed up to speak and two
others that have have logged on and
would request to speak the first
individual um natch Grace from the New
Association Mr Grace are you with
us
yes I'm here Mr chair can you hear me
yes uh so uh my name is n Grace I'm with
the New Hampshire Municipal
Association uh and we oppose this bill
um there are really three reasons uh
that we oppose the bill uh I did hear a
number of questions from Representatives
that I do want to address throughout my
testimony um the first is that tenative
is not defined while it seems pretty
clear that you know the committee has
has an understanding of what that means
it's not defined actually in the chapter
uh nor is it defined as part of this
bill so there could be confusion about
what that means and I think we heard
some of that today um where you know
what what is the tentative agreement uh
for example I used to be a a member of a
union and I was on the negotiating team
and at times we would go and negotiate
with management come back to the union
and say hey we have what we are calling
a tentative agreement the major points
are agreed upon um and everyone in the
union was fine with that but there
wasn't anything written out yet for the
union to vote on and approve um I assume
the similar similarly the same thing
takes place when the select board is
discussing collective bargaining
agreement negotiations among itself in
non-public
session uh and that really plays into
the timeline here because of course if
you have a generalized agreement it may
be the case that there's a sticking
point or two on one side or the other uh
if this has to be posted on the website
you're posting something for 30 days
then going back renegotiating that one
sticking point and again you have
another 30-day period of that it has to
be posted um and that's going to cause
some some serious
concerns uh this second reason that we
oppose this bill is that the cost items
are really the items that the
legislative body that is the towns
people are concerned with they're the
they're the things that cost the money
you know that generally the the towns
people are going to be concerned with uh
you know procedures for um how someone
is uh fired and and how that whole
process works that's not a cost item um
that's something that's negotiated
between the union and the uh the
governing body um it's not something
that the town's people generally have
input on um their
concern as the statutes are written Now
is really with uh the financial aspect
um and all of those cost items have to
be discussed and disclosed with the
legislative body prior to a vote so the
towns people have to understand how much
this contract is going to cost them uh
over whatever period of years that it
runs and each of those items and how
that
functions um all the other non-cost
items are more along the lines of
employer employee relationship um
generally and actually uh you know under
the current statutes uh the town meeting
can't dictate to the select board you
know uh here's how you have to relate to
specific employees and the select for
gets to set those policies those
personnel policies um it doesn't really
make
sense to uh to have that become part of
a vote um and lastly as was pointed out
uh all agreements reached by collective
bargaining um are public records they're
required to be sent to the
plrb uh and those are made available so
um there's already this public access in
addition anyone can go in make a right
to no law request and uh request copies
of any ratified uh agreements um prior
to ratification there's still the
possibility of of
negotiation um occurring I'm happy to
has I don't see any questions here in
the committee room do I see any hands up
online I don't see any
yellow no hands up I apologize
Christina no hands around right now
right thank
you see no questions thank you Mr Grace
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee next individual to speak is
Jim Durkin from the appsme MR Durkin are
us I see your
name Mr Durkin are you on possibly mute
I I I am I sorry there was a little
delay I'm on the phone and and I have to
wait to get unmuted on the screen at the
same time so I appreciate your
patience uh thank you again uh Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record I'm Jim Durkin
legislative agent for ask me Council 93
uh we proudly represent about 4,000
hardworking public sector workers in New
Hampshire of men and women who have been
on the front lines for the past 10
months during the pandemic serving as
police officers 911 dispatches
Corrections Officers Public Works
professionals healthcare workers and and
much more uh I'm here today in in
opposition uh as well to House Bill 348
rep Sullivan's already pointed out the
problems associated with the time
limitations the bill imposed as they
relate to getting the cost items before
the governing body for funding uh I
recorded our position in opposition not
because we're opposed to transparency
but primarily because we believe the
bill has drafted Ed is unnecessary and
may lead to a lot more confusion than
Clarity and uh here's why for starters
and some of this has already been said
but uh all all signed and executed
public sector collective bargaining
Agreements are readily and easily
accessible on the website of the state's
Public Employee Labor Relations Board
the site's easy to find it's easy to
navigate and it's updated regularly in
fact I I checked it this morning and it
was updated just three days ago uh on
January
25th um but as you can see in the
language of the bill it would require a
Public Employee to post notice of a
tentative agreement on any new or
amended collective bargaining agreement
which we believe could create confusion
among the public who we presume uh this
legislation is is aimed at educating on
new contracts now I understand uh from
from the sponsor that uh his efforts are
also aimed at that Ed ating union
members uh but I will say speaking for
our Union uh we don't need any help on
that uh we have a a process that we've
gone through for a long time uh the the
members elect representatives to uh the
bargaining committee and we communicate
with them on a regular basis and give
them ample time to review a tenative
agreement um but again tentative
agreement is just that tentative uh and
the gentleman before me pointed out that
it's it's it's not uh defined in the
bill um but it is defined in Websters as
simply not fully worked out so we're not
sure as to why sponsors of the
legislation would want to notify the
public of an agreement that's yet to be
reviewed and approved by the workers who
would be covered under the contract not
to mention again presented before the
governing body of a municipality for a
vote on cost items uh it's it's
important to note that tenative
agreements that are between the employer
and the union include the original or
current contract language as well as any
new proposed language or changes so this
creates another possibility for
confusion as members of the public might
mistakenly view the entire agreement as
entirely new and view all Associated
cost as completely new additional cost
in other words it could give the
impression that the cost of the contract
is much higher than it it truly is or
the new C uh cost
now if the legislation is aimed at
giving the public uh a chance to oppose
a contract for whatever reason uh then
it's important to note that when a
tenative agreement is finally ratified
or approved by the members who be
covered the law requires that the new
Financial Obligations to the
municipality be presented and voting on
uh by the governing body of the
municipality as the gentleman before we
pointed out thereby making any true new
cost crystal clear to the public in in
providing the public with an opportunity
to weigh in with their elected leaders
if they so choose uh look we're we're
proud of the contracts we secure for our
members we're certainly not looking to
Shield them from public view in fact we
post them on our website too and and
often uh boast of them on social media
because we are proud of them we just
want to be sure that what the public
sees is what is actually approved by our
members through a ratification vote as
opposed to something that again is uh
what's just defined is not fully worked
out and we want the public to know as
they already do under current law what
the true new cost of the contract is uh
we welcome uh an invitation to to work
with the the committee and the sponsor
to refine the language of the bill um
but until such time we ask that you
retain it and I I thank you um for your
uh time consideration and thank you all
for your uh continue service during
these very difficult
times
thank
questions any question in the uh
room seeing none I'm looking online for
yellow hands up or
anything I don't see any uh we don't
have any panelists we do have one more
speaker that has their hands up thank
you he Brian Hawkins yes my next speaker
Hawkins uh thank you Mr chairman can you
hear me all
right yes we can okay terrific um uh
again thank you Mr chairman for the
record Brian Hawkins representing Nea
New Hampshire uh we represent over
17,000 uh members across state in um
public
education and uh I can hear you a little
bit
um there I just trying to put my mic up
is that a little bit
better yes thank you okay terrific um so
I think uh we we also you know have uh
of you know over uh 100 collective
bargaining agreements out there with
school districts and um I'm here I I
signed up similar to Mr Durkin um signed
up in opposition to the bill uh again
not because I think there's any issue
with the intent um but that I think uh
as he said it could be unintentionally
uh misleading to voters um uh so without
going through my entire testimony
because I think uh both M Mr Grace and
Mr Durkin covered most of it you know I
I would Echo uh the points that Mr Gray
made about the tentative agreement not
being defined um you
know the points about the um cost items
is I think is a key one 273
A3 uh Roman 2B states only cost items
shall be submitted to the legislative
body of the public employer for approval
at the next annual meeting of the
legislative body and so if the tenative
agreement with non-cost items is posted
uh as been stated I think that could be
confusing to what it is is in the
purview of the legislative body uh
versus the governing body um as Mr Grace
said the one who is has the employer
employee relationship versus the
taxpayer uh uh uh relationship which is
you know obviously responsible for
funding the contract and I think that's
why when this was uh when 273a was
conceived it was to you know keep those
uh Lanes distinct um for for that
purpose um the uh I I I also think that
tenative agreements take all kinds of
forms when they are um when they are
when they finally are finished I would
Echo some of the concerns about timeline
of of you know dotting the eyes and
crossing the te's on some of these um
complicated issues issues when you're
talking about insurance or uh things
like that but many of them don't will
include the additions to certain
provisions of collective bargaining
agreements or uh or or or the changes
you know the as you're familiar with the
italics and Crossing out of of of of
bills when they're amending
statutes um and so if you don't so
depending on the format it could sort of
go both ways you may have too much of
the picture and as as a voter not be
clear on what it is is in the purview of
of your vote when it comes time to
voting on the uh on the on the
ratification on the warrant which I
think does explain the cost items U for
the for the public or you don't have
enough that you might not realize that
well there's a there's an agreement here
the unions agreed to uh the employers
agreed to a a 5% raise for example and
you as a voter you may
be U outraged that that agreement would
have been reached but what you didn't
know when you read the tenative
agreement was that there was also uh a
provision not on the tenative agreement
that there's a major Savings in the
health insurance for example that
offsets that so um so I think the
unintended consequences of this could be
uh to to uh um ultimately mislead
um voters and as has been stated again
uh you can readily link to the plrb
website where you can see those
agreements um lastly I I just heard the
The Proposal on the amendment um we
would have concerns about that uh as
well and and and what that could do to
back up the process as it is for both
the employers and the employees the
negotiating process does take time
um in some cases you're starting in the
summer before uh you know January um
deadline as representative Sullivan
indicated and uh you know this could
potentially push it back even even
further so I'll close my testimony there
uh and um happy to take any
questions thank you Mr Durkin I'm
looking for questions online I don't see
any hand at this point in the committee
room representative seaworth thank you
Mr chairman um and thank you Mr hoggins
for your uh
testimony there was something I I think
I heard you said and I'm I'm not clear
if I understood it so I'm going to ask
for in uh clarification hopefully I'll
get to the question uh quickly you you
talked a bit about the distinction
between the governing body and the
legislative body uh which have different
roles in in approving specific
spefically the legislative body only
approves cost items the governing body
approves uh the entire
agreement as a voter in the town I I
have roles in both of those I will in a
town meeting town I vote as part of the
legislative body I also elect the
government body um so I
I I'm trying to distinguish between
these two roles and what I I thought you
implied is that the governing body
perhaps sharing
information about a tenative agreement
particularly when they're non-cost items
would not be permitted under the current
law um because of that conflict because
it's not something that as a member of
the legisl body I would be voting on is
was that your implication or no
I to uh thank you for the question
represent not not quite um I guess my
point in in in saying that was that uh
if a tenative agreement is posted I
think it could be uh confusing to voters
as to um what their role is in voting up
or down the warrant uh which contains
the cost items and so um that was my
point in in saying that um
as you said you are voted up or down as
a as a select board member or School
Board member and uh if if I'm a voter
and I don't like the way that you're
running the school district or running
the town you know that's my opportunity
to to vote on that is my
point thank you for the clarification
sure thank you for the question any
other questions in the committee
online Christina I don't see any
questions on the members on Zoom are
there any additional people on Zoom that
would like to
speak I don't see any hands r at this
time thank you I'm going to close the
hearing oh no I apologize um other
individuals that signed up up in in uh
either support or
opposition and Nicole 40 uh member of
the public in
support um Senator Kevin avard in
support Glenn Brackett and the um New
Hampshire AFL CIO opposed Donna Green
School District governance Association
of New Hampshire support Brian real r y
l professional firefighters of New
Hampshire
opposed Eric
Rathburn individual
support representative Tom
Clik
support closing the hearing on House
Bill 348 and we uh will take our lunch
break uh until 1 o'clock when we will be
hearing House Bill
448 uh at 1 o'clock 563 at 2:00 and 2:31
at
3:00 Christina if you'd like to turn off
the
um um or or mute the computer I will
turn it back on when I come in back into
the hearing room if that's okay
absolutely all right Representatives
you
[Music]
m
nowo yes we can hear
you
they we could hear the room but it was
not what I would say good
quality you hear me speaking better
better okay I'm going to step away uh
for the first hearing and Brian's going
to uh take the chair and I'll be back
e
[Applause]
started hearing is on HP
448 I'll open the public hearing on that
and recognize representative Sullivan to
introduce the
Bill thank you Mr chairman
um um House Bill 448 um addresses public
sector
oosha um that is the occu occupational
safety and um uh Health standards for
the public sector uh workers in New
Hampshire if this bill passes it will
establish a study committee that will do
the following first it will compare
safety and health standards that the
occupational safety and health
administration applies to private sector
employees to the New Hampshire
Department of Labor standards that are
applied to New Hampshire public sector
employees thank you you'll also study
the impact adopting um the the impact of
adopting OSHA standards would have on
public sector
employers further it would study the
degree to which New Hampshire public
sector employers I I had a log back in
because I lost my audio for some reason
so what's the question excuse me
somebody out
there is
muted you're not presenting please uh
keep your microphone muted so we don't
interfere with the speaker my apologies
representative suin please continue
thank you
um let's see where we um you'll study
the degree to which New Hampshire public
sector employers may be applying
standards that exceed the standards
currently applied by the New Hampshire
Department of
Labor um you would finally study the
amount of funding that the US Department
of Labor would provide to New Hampshire
to support the implementation of a state
private sector OSHA
plan last year I sponsored a bill that
would have committed New Hampshire to
creating and adopting a state plan for
public sector
oia in the process of moving the bill
through the legislative process um it
became apparent that there were many
unknowns that made it difficult to
commit to a state plan prior to getting
answers to those unknowns this study
committee will provide the information
needed to know what we are committing to
it also gives the committee and more
importantly the New Hampshire Department
of Labor until November of
2022 to complete that
study in new Hamp in in New Hampshire
public sector workers workplaces are
covered by RSA
employees let me give some background on
public sector OIP many people are
unaware
that uh public sector employees in New
Hampshire aren't covered by OIP and many
people are surprised to find out that
they aren't um currently 28 States and
territories have a state oia plan 22 of
those plans I believe were established
when the um when the Act was first um
passed by Congress and those 22 plans
cover private and public sector
workplaces so essentially the state
applies the oia standards to all
employees in those States 22 States six
plans which I believe were adopted um
sometime after the um uh the Act was
passed um six plan Six States cover only
public sector workplaces Federal ocean
covers private sector work uh work sites
in the states and the and and the state
um covers the state uh work workers but
applies the OSHA standards that is a
type of plan that um I would propose for
New Hampshire we would continue to let
the the federal osia cover um private
sector workers um but we would create a
plan that would have public sector
workers also covered by oia standards
but applied by the New Hampshire
Department of
Labor
um adopting an oous uh state plan for
public sector workplaces would leave
public sector health and safety in the
hands of the New Hampshire do but would
use OSHA safety St safety and health
standards for public sector
employees the federal oan program would
continue to cover the private sector
workplaces the new state plan would
cover State County Municipal and public
school
workplaces two important
points the enhancements to the current
health and safety standards would be
supported
by a 50-50 matched funding from the
Federal Department of Labor so we would
be getting federal dollars to help
support
this penalties and fines however would
be established through the process of
developing the state plan and enforced
by the New Hampshire Department of Labor
just as the New Hampshire Department of
Labor um addresses violations in health
um health and safety standards
today the feds do not mandate any
specific levels of fines or
penalties by developing an ocean state
plan for the public sector the 50/50
funding will provide resources that we
presently don't have these resources
would likely include some additional
Staffing but the cost of that Staffing
will more will more than be offset by
funds once in place the New Hampshire
State OSHA plan will provide the
following enhanced health and safety
standards at least as strong as the OSHA
standards
enhanced training for inspectors
employers and
employees enhanced inspection and
investigation procedures the 50-50 uh
federal state funding to cover any
additional costs and part of the costs
that the New Hampshire Department of
Labor presently spends on public sector
health and safety it further offer a
consultancy program new to the public
sector that sends a consultant to a work
site to provide guidance to employers
who want to be Pro proactive about
making sure the workplace is safe this
is not an inspection so it allows an
employer to improve workplace safety
without risk of a
penalty if we eventually adopt State a
state plan for public sector workplaces
we will improve workplace safety bring
Federal funding back to New Hampshire
from Washington and through that funding
will'll provide resources to our
department of labor to conduct
inspections and investigations at a
higher level than ever I emphasize this
is a study committee it will allow us to
make um a fully informed decision if a
public sector oan legislation is
proposed in
20123 and uh with that I will be happy
questions thank you representative are
bill I see none in the committee
online one last time any questions for
the
sponsor seeing none thank you but oh
I Samantha Wooten is has her hand raised
will she be uh someone who wants to
testifying I have a question
representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman um this we heard a
great a great many comments on this when
we brought this forward before it um it
appeared to be a really um big process
that we would have to do but we heard
from um Rudy Ogden on this as well do
you remember some of his comments on
this I believe Rudy Ogden will be um
testifying later so um I guess I will
let him speak for himself um and um uh
leave leave that for later but um I I
would agree that this is a u a fairly
involved process it would take several
years even if we were fully committed
now and frankly the the work of the
study committee is work that we would
have to do um if we had made the
commitment so essentially we're getting
a jump start on the um learning process
um before we make a full commitment to
the U public sector OIP U plan so thank
spor seeing none thank you again for
your
testimony um I now uh have signed up
ahead ahead of time Susie Nord a member
of the public in support of this
bill and if there's someone that could
help I think she needs to be promoted so
she can speak there I see you are
recognized to
speak thank you Mr chair I appreciate it
my name is Susie Nord and I work for the
National Council for occupational safety
and health and I apologize my computer
is getting messages so we may hear beeps
unfortunately if I mute that you won't
hear me um so anyway the National
Council for occupational safety and
health or national Kos our mission is to
advance worker health and safety through
training education research and advocacy
we support the um the bill
because there
is
currently in there's currently statutes
on
the um on the books
which sorry I'm a little distracted by
the messages on my computer I'm not used
or oh my goodness let me start over
again so we're in favor of public sector
OSHA's State plans um because they do a
couple of things right
now public sector employees are under
the jurisdiction of the Department of
Labor the New Hampshire Department of
Labor and that was um has been the case
for actually I believe several decades
but it is it was only put into Statute
in 2019 actually by this committee and
um at that time the testimony of the
department was that they did the best
that they could with the resources that
they had but that they understood that
there is certainly um a PRI the the
federal oosha certainly does a much more
robust investigation of um any incidents
and workplace traumas so um that's one
of the reasons why um and I believe
you'll hear from Samantha Wooten later
and I'll let her speak for herself but
that's one of the reasons um her
father's
um
fatality really brought to light the
shortcomings of what the New Hampshire
Department of Labor is able to do with
the resources that it has to allocate
and um you know the state plan is it's
it's as representative Sullivan said
many many states have them um States
from all over the country of diff of all
different politic iCal um bents as you
will um it's really it's it's a it's a
nonpartisan issue because the the um
original OSHA plan which was passed
actually 50 years ago this year it went
into effect didn't cover public
employees because it didn't want to
bring big government down on the states
and towns it wanted the the states to
take care of themselves and to figure
this out themselves and New Hampshire I
don't believe they did it 50 years ago
but I think it was 20 or 30 years ago
did put some information that at the
time matched what OSHA was doing into
administrative rules and thought that
that was enough because we in New
Hampshire believe in minimal government
interference um but the problem with
that has been that it's much harder for
public employers to know what their um
responsibilities are it's much harder
for the Department of Labor to keep up
with what the latest and greatest that
is going on at the federal level because
the federal government has the resources
to hear um to put in new standards and
to understand what um what the the
latest um research is on occupational um
hazards um so we 100% support this this
has always been sort of a tail wagging
the dog um
or you know
because they don't need to
have legislation to start I mean the
governor could say let's do this and
tell the Department of Labor to do it
however the Department of Labor couldn't
do it without knowing the information
that this study committee is designed to
um to find out because obviously you
don't want to say yes we want to do
something and find out that it costs you
know you I don't even know what the
scale would be but the thing is is that
in the interim while there aren't um
OSHA standards in place for New
Hampshire different departments and
different municipalities and different
Industries such as um the First
Responders police and fire all have some
form of professional safety standards in
place and so one of the things that this
will do is to understand where we are
versus where we need to be to qualify
for the matching funds which would lower
the cost of a what we're doing now and
enable the state of New Hampshire to
offer resources to our smaller towns and
cities and school districts and um fire
departments and that they don't
currently have through this consultancy
program and so the national C supports
this bill 100% and we'll do anything
that we can to help with the committee
and um any questions that anybody has
about it that I can find out so and with
that I'll leave it I apologize for
getting tripped up at the beginning um I
stopped work to to be here and work
didn't stop me so I
apologize all right thank you for your
testimony are there any questions for
this
witness seeing none in the committee
room are is there anyone online with a
question no hands up
today thank you very much and thank you
Miss Nord for your
testimony um next up on my list I have
Deputy Commissioner Rudy
Ogden
uh he is neutral on this bill um but can
inform us as to what is going
on go ahead Mr Ogden uh good afternoon
thank you uh for allowing me the
opportunity to speak to this um to be
clear this was a conversation in the
last uh session talked extensively about
this concept of moving towards an Noha
state plan um as representative Sullivan
indicated in his introduction of this
bill in that discussion there were many
questions related to how far off are we
how much do our standards need to change
where are the cities and towns at
relative to existing OSHA standards so I
would say that I think that the work um
contemplated by this study committee
committee would be work well worth it in
the sense that these are things that
should be answer should be looked at uh
and that would allow individuals to make
a more informed decision going forward
relative to the move towards OSHA State
Standards um I would note it was spoken
to the fact that the Department of Labor
recognizes that it should in and uh has
to do a better job relative to safety
it's something that we you know I think
that every day we try and strive towards
doing more uh across all areas of our
agency's activities but specific to
safety it it is a function in which
we've tried to make improvements over
the last few years I think we have made
improvements but certainly there's
improvements that still have to be made
um I do think that this type of study
committee would help inform certain of
those improvements regardless of whether
ultimately an OSHA state plan is adopted
I think this worth work would be worth
it in the sense of uh giving us a better
barometer of where things are at and
where they should be I'm happy to take
any
questions thank you for your testimony
are there questions for Deputy
Commissioner
Ogden I see none in the committee room
raised um so thank you very much Deputy
Commissioner for your
testimony at this point we've gone
through all the um people who have
signed up to testify ahead of time and I
want to see if there's uh members of the
public who or uh members of the
legislature that are online and want to
speak but did not sign
me right
recognized thank you uh Mr chairman
members of the committee again for the
record Jim Durkin legislative agent for
ask me Council 93 representing 4,000
public sector workers in New Hampshire
I'll be very brief uh we're strongly in
favor of this legislation and we thank
and commend uh representative Sullivan
and the many co-sponsors for for filing
it uh look it it just seems ludicrous
that we would have one set of standards
for the private sector and a separate uh
probably lesser set of standards for uh
the people in the public sector um again
this is just a study who realized that a
lot of work would uh need to be done and
some uh substantial money would need to
be expended to actually Implement
something like this down the road uh but
there's clearly it's hard to argue
against the need to study this and put a
plan in place uh I think uh you know es
especially the the need for this has
always been there uh but now with the
the covid-19 uh pandemic uh I think it
it becomes even stronger and clearer uh
that we need to get a good system in
place to protect public sector workers I
thank you again for your
time thank you very much for your are
questions I see no hands raised in the
committee room any questions from
online seeing none thank you again for
your
testimony thank you
sir are there any other members of of
the public that wish to testify we have
uh one more we have Samantha
W Samantha Ruben you are recognized
speak thank you very much good sorry for
massacring your name I can't read that
okay good afternoon chairman and Ladies
and Gentlemen of the committee I
sincerely appreciate your time and
attention today and I would like to
thank you for allowing me to speak
before you if I interrupt you your um
your voice is kind of low and difficult
to hear
can uh enhance that a little we'd
sure is that any
better not
still difficult I will try to understand
go
ahead is it possible for me to call in
on my cell
phone um that is an option that if you
dial into the number and uh
let us know what the number is we can
promote that number so you can turn off
the microphone on your computer and
speak through the phone I'm very sorry
about
problem is there another uh individual
or uh no other speakers at this time
come
on
for
my phone number is connected
now okay can we see what that is and
it so if you press star n you should be
able to
um um actually star six excuse me you
unmute there we go there we go I'm so
sorry is better thank you very much we'd
all like to hear what you to say
um again I sincerely thank you for your
time and attention and for allowing me
to speak before you again I'm here in
support of House Bill
448 on July 21st of 2016 my life was
forever changed my father Tom won worked
for the town of northfield's Department
of Public Works and on this day the
employees were moving a trailer with a
bucket in a backo there were two
equipment operators and two flaggers my
dad was one of the flaggers
while approaching the end location my
father was fatally pinned between the
trailer and the
loader excuse me I apologize um it is
still unclear how and why my father is
caught in between the two machines the
accident crushed his pelvis causing
internal injuries that killed him I am
by no means an expert on workplace
safety however I am taking the necessary
steps to gain the Insight while
obtaining my m 's degree in occupational
safety I would have thought that since
this accident resulted in the tragic and
untimely death of my healthy father
there would have been a thorough
investigation or potentially a root
cause analysis I was proven wrong I do
not place blame on the town of
Northfield or the Department of Labor I
believe they did the best they could
with the funding and administrative
support they had behind them at the time
if the state of New Hampshire more
specifically the town of Northfield were
held to the same standards I may know
what it would happened to my dad I still
may not that's obvious that's an issue
as well but there was no accident
reconstruction to find out what happened
there was no follow-up interviews with
the employees that were on scene and
again i' would like to say I understand
that the Department of Labor did not
have the capability to do that the lack
of Investigation however did make me
feel as though my father's death meant
nothing and it was somehow not as
important as a public sector employee
where OSHA has jurisdiction if this was
a private sector business OSHA would
have been there almost immediately
beginning an investigation and
implementing a plan of action to ensure
that a tragic accident like my father's
would not happen again throughout my
journey from my father's passing up
until this day I have met so many
incredible individuals who work
tirelessly to ensure the safety of
others safety and occupational in the
occupational stance is oftentimes pushed
to the sidelines because it comes with
an expense or may stall a project
deadline but I truly want you all to
think about the ones you love is there a
price you would pay to ensure they
returned home safely every
day clearly this is a painful topic for
me to discuss and even more painful to
live my life without seeing my dad's
bright eyes and handsome smile I'm using
my voice today and every day because I
do not want another daughter to feel the
heartache that I feel daily I believe
it's time for action and it needs to be
clear that every worker in whatever
capacity they are employed should have
the same basic safety rights on a side
note I also agree that this is a
nonpartisan issue safety is nonpartisan
I I have spoken time and time again with
the governor and he supports the
committee I just it's important to take
care of the public employees that take
care of us on a daily basis and I thank
you for your time thank you for your
testimony the committee appreciates that
you shared such a personal story I'm
loss are there questions um for this
this
Witness
I see none in the committee room anybody
question seeing none once again I thank
you for your
testimony and thank
you one last do we have anyone uh online
testify no hands at this time
uh seeing
none I
will close the public hearing on this
bill uh uh Mr chairman uh there wasn't
you were supposed to read the folks oh
and I'm
sorry I meant to do that uh we have a
longer list of people who signed up on
our virtual blue sheet so I'll read
through the names and if applicable who
they
represent uh we have Nicole 40 Mary
Bole and Evan oxenham all in support all
members of the public and I I'll
apologize in advance for everybody's
name that I get wrong we have
representative Lee
oxenham uh
representing suin District
One we have wilred Mont Smith Lissa
py Judith
stadman um and Larry Ballard all members
of the public in support and if I I may
have missed saying it representative
oxenham uh is in
support we have Glenn bracket
representing the New Hampshire aflci in
support
um Dr Reverend Dr Gail
Kenny uh representing the New Hampshire
Conference United Church of Christ
economic Justice team in
support uh Cullen Tian of the sea
SEIU
1984 um in
support representative Diane
Shu um uh co-sponsor of the bill in
support and Eric rathan uh a member of
the public in
support thank you for the
reminder and our next bill is scheduled
for two
then
my phone going computer does everyone
Brian did you open and close it with
your
P so I'm guessing when if I were to log
on to zoom just like you two
are Christina could probably give us the
control yes to do this
stuff that something we want to under
take me no no we oh we we oh
yeah I think think between a bunch of us
and figured it
out thank you do I hear volunteers to
take
it because after you know we're going to
we're going to be able to finish
probably our hearings in three sets
three days then after that much of it's
going to be some um executive sessions
for us so at this point the public can
listen and then it's just the
representatives um so that that I can
see being a little easier I just gotta
somehow get some find some tutorial
whether Christina you can find me one I
looked on YouTube YouTu and and zoom and
I could not find one that shows me how
to manage what you're doing
something Mr
chairman um I had a I had a I had a
brief session with Christina and a few
just a handful of other members and she
was very informative and uh as far as
promoting and demoting that sort of
thing it's really just a couple of
clicks
all right excellent so in case anyone
didn't know Mike represent kahill has
so yeah thanks uh M Mr chairman the
other point I'd like to make is far as
executive sessions we've often had um
people from the agencies or other
interested parties that sometimes put
their two cents and and U sometimes it's
helpful you're correct it has been in in
in in years past I will agree with you
and I'm sure uh all of you that have
served on this committee will testify to
the fact that when we are sitting here
at deliberation every once in a while
something gets brought up and a lobbyist
or someone from the
uh Gallery have had provided some you
know some pretty good information to
while some to make their
decisions um yeah we have to try to play
that by
year
Eastern Standard
Time a open house bill
563 establishing a committee to study a
living wage utilization of Public
Assistance among low wage workers and
their families in New Hampshire and the
first Speaker I have is uh to introduce
representative thank you uh Mr chair
thank you members of the labor
committee and thank you everyone here
today for the record I am representative
Tony Kaplan mayor Max 6 which is the
towns of hener and
Bradford this bill is intended to set up
a commission to study the wages
necessary in different parts of the
state that would allow workers and
Working Families of different
configurations to actually meet their
basic
needs it will also look at what it costs
the state and New Hampshire taxpayers to
make up the difference when wages do
fall short of those
needs uh the pandemic we've been going
through for almost a year now has
greatly exacerbated some of the strains
that were already facing low wage
workers in New
Hampshire uh we know for example that
hunger has increased homelessness has
increased just to mention a couple of
the
indicators um of suffering but even
before the pandemic things were not
great for low-wage workers across the
state uh despite the Boom in jobs low
unemployment and gains for top level
earners we can AR about Solutions what's
appropriate what is ideologically sound
and we often do but we need to have a
shared set of funds I mean a shared set
of facts before uh we can begin to
discuss what is needed and craft
appropriate policies to bring us out of
this pandemic and start building a state
where everyone can uh everyone can
Thrive Working Families businesses a
single mother a couple or working family
struggling to put food on the table
things look very different in different
regions of our state and one-size
solutions just will not do uh let's take
a quick look at what we do know and the
partial idea of what we might need to
know in order to decide what a living
wage in the different regions of New
Hampshire would actually look
like uh different regions in New
Hampshire show great disparities in
wages and job opportunities these
disparities also exist when you look at
the cost of living but in general across
New Hampshire increases in cost of
living especially housing along with
stagnant wages for the bottom half of
workers has led difficult economic
realities for thousands of granite
Staters median family income in 2017
ranged from 45,000 in Coos County to
85,000 in Rockingham County we all know
there's a north south divide in New
Hampshire when it comes to Economic
Opportunity and we need to take this
into account when we devise uh policy
Solutions but across the state wages
below the 50% median have been stagnant
for the decade or more decade or more
even before the Corona virus hit uh
we've all heard about how great the
economy was doing before the pandemic
and it's true that the New Hampshire
economy was growing and unemployment
numbers were falling but behind these
figures lurked growing inequality and
stress for Working Families trying to
keep up with an economy that was not
geared to protect or much less favor
essential Workers Health Care Service
Providers restaurant Supermarket
employees Etc let's look at these job
growth numbers we had before the
pandemic and most of these figures are
from either the New Hampshire fiscal
policy Institute or the Center on budget
and policy
priorities from 2008 to
2018 the net increase in jobs was
27,500 the industries with the largest
job growth were health care and social
assistance with 11,000 jobs
administrative and waste service with
8,000 jobs professional and Technical
Services with 7,000 jobs accommodation
and food service with 7,000 jobs
Educational Service with 2,600 jobs
and transportation and warehousing with
2,000 jobs of these industries that were
the largest drivers of job growth all of
them except professional and Technical
Services have average weekly wages below
the Statewide average of a thousand per
week or 27 $27 an hour only workers
making more than this average have seen
their wages increase to levels before
the Great Recession of
2008 it's true that the tight labor
market in New Hampshire has helped push
lower wages higher
however workers earning incomes below
the average have barely had their
purchasing power restored to pre2 2008
levels workers who earned an average
wage or less over this period have
experienced what feels like a pay cut
workers earning at the 20th percentile
or lower in other words 16 or $17 an
hour have experienced what feels like a
very drastic pay cut and all this comes
before the pandemic as far as the cost
of living let's get housing low wage
work workers the majority of them
renters have experienced and are
experiencing a severe shortage of
housing available in our state from 2014
to 2019 rental costs have increased by
nearly 22% for a two-bedroom apartment
in New Hampshire uh vacancy rate of
units across the state sits at below
1% according to the US Department of
Housing and Urban Development families
who pay more than 30% of their income
for housing are considered cost burdened
and may have difficulty affording
Necessities such as food clothing
transportation and medical
care may have difficulty meeting their
basic needs that's important because
this is what we would be concerned with
in a study of the sort commissioned by
this bill workers who cannot meet their
basic needs for food heating
Transportation Etc based on the most
recent estimates from 2017 approximately
47% almost half of New Hampshire's
renters were spending more than 30% of
their income on rental costs in other
words almost half of renters in New
Hampshire meet that cost burden Federal
criteria and may have difficulty making
ends meet do we know how many of these
renters are full-time workers I would
like to know and I think it would give
us a clear picture of the difficulties
facing low wage earners in the state the
other question is how many of these
workers are depending on safety net
programs to supplement their salaries
and meet their basic needs I believe uh
we as taxpayers have a right to know
what kind of companies are these
potential cost burden employees working
for I think it's one one thing uh if
they're working for a small family
business in Coos or Grafton County and
another thing if they're working for a
large corporation in nashille or
Hillsboro County but we can't begin to
discuss the problem and devise policy
until we have a shared set of facts we
can agree
upon if we intend to ensure that working
people in New Hampshire can work
full-time jobs and pay their way with
dignity without relying on tax
subsidized safety net services or
private charity we need to know how many
of them fit into this description of
cost burden and unable to meet their
needs despite employment we do know that
federal and state sa safety net programs
lift an estimated 140,000 New Hampshire
ites above the poverty line each year
how much of this taxpayer money is going
to prop up business bottom lines who
owners whose owners are raking in
profits while their employees rely on
welfare programs to meet their basic
needs if we decide we don't need to know
are we saying that this is
okay a living wage is not a minimum wage
we all know that New Hampshire is the
only state in New England that still
follows the federal minimum wage of 725
remained
representative
representative uh can we seem to have
lost the representative who is
testifying representative Klan Kaplan
can the rest of you folks on Zoom hear
me
okay yes uh we're he is not muted we
audio all right we'll wait a minute here
to see if he can
um maybe re reboot or something here we
only have one other person to testify
and we have some
opportunity representative Kaplan if you
can hear us we cannot hear you please
try to relog
to what I'm going to do folks is Wait
Another Minute here and then I'm going
to call on the second speaker if
representative Kaplan is then able to
come back on um he can
testify after this next uh the second uh
speaker we do have two additional
speakers um to add to the list just so
you know did you email me those I have
my phone charging right now I will do
that no no you don't have to I just
not
well
what if he come gets back on later we
can let him all right Christina I'm
going to call next if representative
Kaplan comes in um you can keep him in
the queue and then you can let me know
I'd like to introduce our second speaker
Reverend Dr Gail Kenny New Hampshire
Team all right she's available and able
unmutes
Reverend
Miss
Kenny are we away from her computer but
she's still
muted uh Christina would you please um
um invite the third
speaker yes I can bring on Kathy stab
from raise up New
Hampshire what where one more time
y hello can everyone hear
me yes okay thank you um thank you for
giving me this opportunity to um speak
to you today about this bill um I'm a
member of raised up New Hampshire and
we're a group of um faith-based um labor
and Grassroots organization that work on
economic justice issues in the state and
um I would like to uh say that I'm in
favor of House Bill 563 which would
establish a committee to determine the
level of living wages in various parts
of the State of New Hampshire um in the
interest of transparency I think it is
also important for taxpayers to
understand how much we spend in
corporate welfare to provide basic human
needs when companies pay their workers
far less than a living wage more
important than that I think it is useful
for the state to understand what graters
are spending to live this type of thing
is done in other states and I've sent an
email to the committee that included
links um to um other states reports that
would be similar to this one our New
Hampshire Constitution states that the
state government derives its power from
the consent of the Govern the
legislature makes policy decisions and
appropriates resources to benefit our
state's economy these decisions should
not be limited to ensuring profits for
the few but also seek to improve the
quality of life of the many our
constitution also says that our
government is instituted for the general
good and that people of New Hampshire
have the right to seek and obtain
happiness given that I think it is the
responsibility of our elected government
to be aware of what it takes for New
Hampshire's residents to live a health
healthy stable and happy life I believe
that the information gathered under this
proposal would help the government of
the State of New Hampshire make better
policy decisions regarding things like
minimum wages but it would also help to
inform decisions about where the state
needs to invest its
resources where is housing too expensive
where do we need more support for child
care where do we need more reliable
internet we do this with roads um we
should also be making smart investments
in quality of life in infrastructure for
our
people when Granite Staters have
stability it will release their P
potential to build stronger communities
and a more vibrant economy New Hampshire
is a state where deaths currently exceed
births for a net loss and natural
population growth we rely on moving on
people moving in from other states to
maintain our population of working age
people um it's particularly difficult
and challenging for families um and I've
I've also put in a link to a New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute study
from a couple of years ago that that
shows that we need to treat our people
as the tremendous asset that they are
and support them in ways that will help
them Thrive the information we gather
with this proposal will help us do that
thank
you thank you do I have any questions uh
room no questions to Comm room do I have
any questions for the speaker um on Zoom
see any hands or any yellow raised
hands Christina I don't see any No Hands
um I do have representative Kaplan back
okay um thank you very much Miss St and
um I'd like to call again uh
Kaplan
go
ahead okay hi sorry I I lost my uh
connection there sorry about that um I
guess I'll just pick up where I was
um a living wage is not a minimum wage
we all know that New Hampshire is the
only state New England that still
follows a federal minimum wage of 7025
an hour uh but a living wage is the
actual wage that workers need to earn in
order to meet their basic needs food
plus Child Care Plus Health Health Care
Plus housing transportation and other
necessities uh the living wage has been
calculated in different places using
different parameters but in general it's
a tool to guarantee workers and working
families are self-sufficient and able to
stand on their own feet to meet their
needs isn't that all of our aim
regardless of
Ideology Now this commission if
established by Statute would have the
power to determine the parameters and
organizations to carry out the study
geared to finding out living wage would
be in different parts of the state I
believe the state agency the economic
and labor Market information Bureau part
of the New Hampshire employment security
agency which is federally funded the F
the bureau develops and disseminates
labor market information and measures
labor market outcomes to assist public
officials private employers Educators
and trainers this is from their website
I believe they would be the indicated
agency to carry out this research and I
trust that being taxpayer funded to do
this sort of work that the cost of the
legislature would be minimal in
conclusion the pandemic has made it all
the more visible that as a society we
often function as if we didn't depend on
the labor of underpaid essential workers
our grocery clerks warehouse workers par
Educators carers for the elderly and for
children cleaners Hospital staff and
others in our lowest paying but
absolutely indispensable Fields the time
we dedicated ourselves to having a close
look at the gap between the wages that
are unoffered for these people and the
costs necessary for them to survive in a
self-sufficient and dignified manner now
I recognize that the idea of a living
wage is seen as a progressive policy
agenda but look that close ly I think
Ronald Reagan would have approved of the
actual intent which is to wean the
private sector off the habit of relying
on public funds to keep their employees
fed sheltered and with their basic
health care and child care needs
met I'll leave off there and if there
any questions Mr chair I'll try to
answer them thank you again and thank
you to the fellow members of the labor
committee thank you representative
Kaplan the chair does have a few
questions but beforehand i' like to know
if any of my fellow Representatives
online have any questions for
representative
Kaplan
not seeing any hands up any questions of
room see n robers Kaplan this is Will
infantine um have did you speak at all
with the Department of Labor and
Department of Employment Securities to
see if they have the bandwidth uh to
take this on and whether or not they
already provide some of this information
um it's just part of their information
um
deposit every quarter or every year I
did I did not uh Mr chair I did not
speak to anybody at the labor department
um I did research through uh the the
internet and I just looked at what this
uh agency that I mentioned in my in my
uh in my talk to this now the uh
economic and labor market information
Bureau which is part of the Employment
Security Agency is uh charged with doing
this sort of research and I looked at
what they have online and there's
nothing that specifically targets a
living wage
okay thank you um I'm getting old but I
recall um a few years ago did this did
the state or did a committee such as
this undertake this to come up with the
number a few years ago in the
legislature as far as I know Mr chair
that that didn't happen there was a I
think there was some
legislation uh in the previous session
that that was tabled but that's my
understanding commission has never
actually been set up thank you and this
is one of these those you believe would
you believe questions representative
would you believe I don't think a lot of
senators are into going on these study
committees and you might want to reduce
the uh the number to one since I hear
that they're not being too favorable to
study committees these days if you would
believe well I think the the number is
too but yes that's an amendment that uh
you know that's actually practical
absolutely any other questions from the
members here in the
committee room any I see a hand off I
believe that is representative to me is
that
correct yes yes it is uh quick question
uh representative C Kaplan uh have you
put a copy of your testimony up uh on
the internet so that we can take a look
at it I will do that I have not but I
will certainly share that with with your
committee okay thanks a lot
you're
welcome okay I don't see any further
questions we do have a few other people
in the queue thank you very much
representative Kaplan is Doc Reverend Dr
Gail
us Reverend Kenny um yes um yes Mr chair
um I'm here I don't know what happened
before and I apologize for that
something kflu with the um the audio uh
this time around with this hearing but
sorry about that so honorable chair and
members of the committee my name is Gail
Kenny um I'm a resident of Kanan and I'm
a minister with the United Church of
Christ and I'm speaking today on behalf
of the economic Justice team of this
particular New Hampshire denomination um
just so you know the United Church of
Christ um many people also just know us
as the
congregationalists is the largest
Protestant denomination in New Hampshire
um I'm also an ongoing contact with uh
individuals from a number of Faith
communities and I believe that there is
widespread support among Faith leaders
for the kind of study that's envisioned
in House Bill
563 so in religious circles in our
circles we often use the word
discernment uh to describe the process
by which we look deeply with a moral
lens into matters of concern that have
an impact on our Collective Humanity so
that we can make good decisions about
our actions and so that we can
understand their impact we also believe
that Discerning or seeking a
comprehensive understanding of the lived
realities of individuals in our
communities is a really really important
component of public policym and for this
reason we believe that a legislative
study committee um with the purpose
which is outlined in um House Bill
563 will be of immense assistance to all
Committees of the general court and
especially those that deal with
Workforce issues and economic
development issues and safety net
Services issues um the reality is I I
think you heard a moment ago
that some of the fastest growing sectors
in the New Hampshire economy um in
non-pandemic times are lower wage
sectors um of our economy and that
includes retail food service and I want
to emphasize home health and some of the
lower paid um Health Care uh jobs um
both those scen and those behind the
scenes and and there are more but those
are some critical ones retail Food
Service home health and if I were a
state legislator today I would
definitely want to know the impact on
our state and our communities um of of
this kind of work and the wages that are
paid and how much and I would really
like to know how much it costs us in tax
dollars to subsidize workers in these SE
sectors um I'd want to understand the
implications uh
particularly um when I learn that there
are major corporations that are active
in New Hampshire that actually coach or
educate their their low-wage employees
on how to access taxpayer supported
services so that they can supplement
their low wages and still survive in the
state of New Hampshire and I want to be
clear about one thing I and we
absolutely do not begrudge helping such
workers with Services um that are
supported by our tax dollars but I think
it's our moral imperative and our
calling um to not just assist our
neighbors in need need but also
understand the Dynamics that are
creating their need and I'd want to
know that um by subsidizing corporate
the corporate profit sheet how much is
that costing us I think that we really
need to understand that Dynamic um and
an additional point there are many
excellent resources um Employment
Security is just one in the work that
they do but that they other work uh
resources in the community um that I
won't speak for directly but but a
number of um analytical organizations um
economic analytical organizations that
would really be willing to support um
such a committee and provide resources
provide statistics and provide analyses
right now in terms of driving public
policymaking I don't think there's any
one place where someone can go and get
get the kind of analytical information
that's that's um envisioned in this bill
but we need it and you need it I think
in order to do the most effect effective
policymaking so overall I just I would
strongly urge you and implore you uh to
support and ought to pass on this
particular Bill and to engage in the
kind of legislative discernment that is
so critical um to try trying to make
good decisions will have a positive
impact on all of the communities of our
state so I thank you very much for your
time thank you for your testimony do
have any questions from the committee
L I see none any questions of the
members on Zoom I think I see one
gentleman with his hand up I's
scratching his nose or asking question
any questions to the members
online I see representative Chris
chairman
than representative
question I can bring her on um we're not
able to hear you very well I was hoping
to testify so it wasn't a question for
the
Reverend okay if you could hold please I
was uh sorry it was difficult for you to
hear me I had my uh speaker off again so
I will ask this
case people not hear me are there any
questions of any members of um the
Reverend um in the in the
lb seeing none any members of the
committee online any questions for um
the
Reverend seeing none I do have a
question
um there you're the second speaker in a
row to talk about corporate welfare
subsidizing corporate profit sheets
could you tell me if are if there are
and if they are who the names of these
corporations are in New Hampshire that
are
are that you feel we are subsidizing
because they're paying low wages and I'm
being sincere with my question I I'm not
aware of this yes
um absolutely
um there are um let's just say Walmart
for example is um one of the largest
employers in the nation and um Walmart
has
consistently um provided resources to
their employees on how to access Public
Services um knowing I think that full
well that that many if not most of their
Frontline workers um don't earn enough
to thrive and in order to be able to
survive or to support a family in New
Hampshire um McDonald similarly has
provided um resources and information to
um to their to their employees um on on
how to um access services that at one
point um they had an an an online um
system to help employees try to plan um
their economic resources you know in
order to be able to thrive or to survive
actually and um I I don't have specific
information about others but I could
certainly get that for you but the
reality is that uh we're really talking
about major out ofate corporations um
who play low pay low wages but
understand that in order to keep their
workers coming back to work they've got
to help them in other ways in order to
to thrive and so they do this by saying
you know this is how you can access
these Services you know whether it's
food stamps or whether it's healthy kids
or um heating assistance or whatever it
might be and we need to understand that
Dynamic I think it's really critical I
would like to understand it for the
State of New Hampshire and and I hope
all all of you would as well all right
thank you we have another question here
in thetive office building
um representative representative
adjutant thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you Reverend kinea um would you believe
me if I told you that according to
forbes.com uh Walmart's low wage workers
cost us taxpayers an estimated 6.2
billion in public assistance including
food stamps and snap where Walmart eats
up 18% of all snap recipients would you
agree with that statement I would
absolutely believe what you're saying
question would you accept another
Reverend um is there another question
yes please if you'd hold for another
question go ahead
representative uh thank you Reverend for
taking the followup uh to follow up on
my last question would you agree uh
would you believe me if I said that two
of the members of the Walton family who
notoriously own the Walmart corporation
are each worth $54 billion a piece and
are ranked number eight and number nine
respectively on the Forbes annual list
of
billionaires well is that's a resource
you have I would absolutely believe it
there's similar information that's been
out there for
years all right thank you any if there's
no any more questions for the
Reverend seeing none thank you very much
for your
testimony and thank
you and Christina is there one
additional individual who would like to
speak yes we have Viola cat kusmi uh
from Granite State
organizing
before I I um before I recognized Viola
um was there another representative
there's a there's a I can't see the
screen is a very small picture yes
Schultz okay is it okay
um I don't see viola on the screen so um
if You' like we can let representative
Schultz yes please I'd like to recognize
representative
Schultz
representative can you hear me yes ma'am
oh thank you Mr chair and colleagues of
the labor committee um I'm gonna be very
brief I think this is a great bill I
became obsessed with this topic after a
briefing with the New Hampshire fiscal
policy Institute on what it is to live
in New Hampshire and how EXP expensive
it is to live in New Hampshire um
because the the default on living wages
that the New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute uses is the
MIT uh living wage
calculator and it only goes by County so
not only are you uh aggregating
Hillsboro County with Manchester and
nsha and all of their surrounding or
many of their surrounding towns but then
you're also putting with marac County
aaging in a wealthy town like New London
with
Pittsfield uh and I could go county by
county on how that doesn't work um that
also includes issues around
transportation that aren't factored in
issues around um the dependence on the
property tax in most towns and cities in
New Hampshire and uh it also these this
information is important to Economic
Development groups who try to sell New
Hampshire as a place for especially
high-tech workers to come and live my
husband is a software engineer and you
know so say he were looking at he's
lived in New Hampshire his whole life
but let's use him as an example you know
it wouldn't just be someone like my
husband looking for work here but me too
you know and I the low wage job as a
State Rep so $100 a year haha okay I
bombed on my joke but oh well
you know what I'm talking about um but
anyway that's why I feel that this is
very necessary this bill is because we
we can't just use the county aggregate
aggregated information and as someone
who is advocated for a minimum wage
specific to New Hampshire issues of how
much it costs to live in New Hampshire
is something that we should all be
considering as we look at the
$725 an hour so this data this
information we would Gather By A study
would be useful in so many ways to make
sure that the workforce that we need uh
has what it's has what it needs to
survive and anything else I would say
would be repeating what the other folks
have already said Thank
you thank you any questions from uh the
representatives on
[Music]
Zoom I don't see any representatives in
the
L representative this is will infantine
I do have a question
um I don't
doubt
the the importance of getting this
information my concern and I'd like to
know your response to it is that this is
a herculan effort with something that
you'd pay a company you know $200,000 a
year to put together and you're asking
three representatives and two senators
uh with the help of the Department of
Labor and appointment security is are a
little tasked right now uh to try to get
something done by November 1st
um I mean the calculus the the the
statistics and everything required in
that is this something that's going to
be manageable by these individuals I
would say Mr chair sure these are things
you can think about but looking at the
questions in and of themselves to
determine that uh doesn't cost any money
in and of itself uh
maybe that is what the study would come
up with is what it would cost to track
this on an ongoing basis but I think we
have enough
information uh before us that it
wouldn't require that much that many
resources overall I think I'm probably
not the right person to determine how
much that would be but um this would be
a benefit to everybody to have this
information and to even assess what is
needed to live in today's Society I I
failed to mention that one of the things
that the MIT calculators also doesn't
include is child care costs which if
you're a family that needs child care
that eats up such a large portion of
your income it's amazing same for if
your health care bills are higher
because your plan is crappier or you're
between the ages of 26 and
64 uh it also doesn't include student
loan debt so when looking at the issues
around living wage simply by determining
the things that cost money nowadays in a
modern society in an expensive State
like New Hampshire I don't think uh that
exploration in and of itself would need
to be uh expensive but it can outline
what that would need to be on an ongoing
basis that would be more expensive for
sure so I don't know that I can I don't
think I answered your question but I do
think that the exploration of this
is of such benefit um that the shortterm
work of this study would be very
helpful thank you any questions the
members of the
LLB see none any members or the
representative online on
Zoom I do not see any hands I do
actually have Viola um has arrived and
would be ready to speak all right
Christina what is biola's last
name uh it is
Kimi I hope that's
um Mr
cini uh your call to
bill you'll just have to unmute
ma'am hello can you hear me yes we can
VI
great uh good afternoon chairman intini
and members of the House committee for
the record is Viola C and I'm
representing the gr State organizing
project uh the gr State organizing
project is a grassroot nonpartisan
organization that brings Faith labor and
Community groups together to work for a
more just World um I'm here to express
our support for HB
563 through our work in community
organizing we've had several stories
from full-time workers who have to
depend on public assistance to care for
their families uh what we hear from time
and again is that these Working Families
have time to se their programs because
they canot support themselves through
work since their wages are so
low uh what we have to ask ourselves is
why why are these workers who are
already doing their part contributing to
our economy and the wellbeing of their
families why are they working 30 35 40
hours a week and they still need that
helping hand in form of housing
assistance would stamp um I believe that
from the previous speakers and what we
already know in terms of the data that's
available that we may already have some
of the answers to why that is uh we know
that some Industries and large
corporations uh some of them have chosen
to pass on their obligation of paying
workers at decent wage that is needed to
afford basic needs to taxpayers
um and also we cannot ignore the fact
that wages for Lage workers have
stagnated over the years while the
living costs continue to rise uh we also
know that our neighboring New England
states have pass and V to raise the
minimum wage whereas New Hampshire's
minimum wage defaults to the federal
rate of $725 an hour the lowest in the
region so for most Lage workers who are
heads of households $7 an hour 25
cents an hour $725 C an hour $8 even 12
even 15 cannot help them to afford the
basic needs that they need without
getting that
assistance um studies that have been
done and some of them have already been
qued by some of the um previous
speakers uh one of them includes the
economic policy Institute they have a
family budget calculator and I would
encourage all of you to check it out um
and they estimate that if you one
working adult with a child in Caro
County you need about
$59,000 annually or an equivalent of
$4,997 a month to attain a modest
standard of living so we know some of
the information exists but I know that
we might not be a fully in support of
all the information that is collected by
Economic Policy Institute we have an
opportunity here for New Hampshire to
collect our own data and analyze on data
so with HB
563 we can determine how many working
people in our Outpost are utilizing
Public Assistance we can determine what
New Hampshire's basic needs budget is we
can determine what a living wage is for
workers to sustain themselves working
fulltime we can also determine how we
can repurpose some of the funds that
workers are relying on that they may not
meet once we have policies in place that
can lift our wages and we can recoverus
those fund for other programs and people
that need it the most so through the
committee's finding I hope that New
Hamshire can get on a path to helping
working families and businesses that are
doing their fair share I like to
encourage um the committee members to
look at the study that bont did in
2017 they had a um I believe it was
called The Living wage study committee
and they looked at different aspects of
what was happening in B in different
parts of the state they looked at what
their B basic need budget was they
looked at the cost um it looked at wages
they looked at what implications would
be if wages were raised um and that
information really helped them to inform
their policies and Vermont is one of the
states that has a higher wage than New
Hampshire their current minimum wage is
$175 cents an hour where we below um
where we higher than what we have
currently yeah so I would like to urge
committee members support HB
563 and vote out to pass on this bill
just one last point that I have to make
um I had um the committee asked from
information on some of the companies in
New Hampshire that we are subsidizing um
I would like to direct you to Americans
for fair tax uh Americans for fair for
tax fairness it's a report that was
published in
2014 and they list uh different states
and different companies and actually
Walmart is one of the main companies
listed on there and they really show us
how many of their workers um are relying
on subsidies and what that cost is in
terms of of of of taxpayers money so um
I'm happy to send this to Comm members
but that's just a portion and so this
study would help us to assess what other
companies are out there that we're not
aware of so I hope that you consider
passing this legislation thank you very
much thank
you any questions from any members here
L see none any from the members of the
Zoom don't see any am I missing
anything uh no do I don't see any hands
all right thank you Viola we appreciate
your
testimony um are there any other uh
individuals wishing to
legislation in the que no no okay I'm
going to read a list of individuals that
have signed
in uh you know just before I continue um
representative seaworth or anyone else
uh four years ago we started doing this
is this no longer the procedure uh
representative Sullivan to read the
people that uh who had uh did not
testify uh but have um usually the blue
cards or I have to confess that last
year I didn't do it but I would say I
should have um I I think it's a good
practice all right well I'll continue on
here uh Robin uh snell a member of the
uh a member of the public is in support
Cynthia Perkins state agency staff is in
support Jose Pinto a lobbyist New
Hampshire youth movement in support
Janet leup New National employment law
project in support Richard Maynard
individual member of the public in
support Nicole 40 in support Ben CR
Kramer in support uh Jones Rebecca Jones
ball in
support Evan oxenham in support
representative that was representative
oxenham from Sullivan County District 1
in support representative Linda Gould uh
in opposed repr Linda ghoul
opposed
uh wilam Mt Smith supports David halt
supports Lissa py supports Judith
statman supports Jason weissbrot
support Emma Cody
support Glenn Brackett the working
people of New Hampshire AFL CIO support
Susan Vil elected official
representative Susan Vil Hillsboro
County 13 support Eva Kaplan support
Lucius Marshall
support cullin Tian sea SEIU
1984 support Susan cren
support Karan Anderson support Marsha
feder
support Louise Spencer support jeie
torley support June Garen support
Mel heinbach support Susan Richmond
support Mora willing support Eric
ruthburn support Claudia istel support
Kathy Spielman support James Spielman
support Moren ellerman support and Jay
Newton
support I don't have any other
additional folks in the queue to testify
I will close the hearing on House Bill
563 we will resume at 3:00 for House
Bill
all right guys years and years ago I
learned in the legislature that
um Walmart had this thing going on in
Alabama or Mississippi so they knew that
if you made under a certain salary a
year you could benefit you could get um
U Alabama paid Healthcare so they made
sure all their employees are under
that so that kind of struck me
so I boycott Walmart I'm one of the only
people I yell at my wife if I ever see a
freaking Walmart bag in the
house so I'd like to see everybody do
that because I think they're uh good for
their stockholders and terrible for the
general public that's just me I've G on
record that I hate Walmart but that's
just me cuz I think they do I think they
got some really smart people who play
the game really
badly
but sorry that's
my personal opinion well they don't have
to you know it's it's a game they play
and they go to certain places so they
can uh uh get tax credits or they do
this or they do that really smart people
they utilize the system well but
sometimes I I question you know I'm I'm
an insurance business so when they took
out a bunch of life insurance policies
on a lot of their employees we're not
talking about key part you know people
and we're talking about they buy these
General life insurance policies for all
these managers all these stores all over
the country because someone did the math
to figure out a certain propensity of
them will die any given year just by
either natural causes or or accidents or
what have you so they go out without
them knowing buy4 million dollar life
insurance policy on these 40 30 year
olds when they passed
I'm all for capitalism but you you got
to stop somewhere there's ethics
involved that's
something
question so I I put my money where my
mouth was I
stopped shall a
Walmart now I know that you know even
I've had to in a bind you know my
daughter rore M is's playing
soccer and we get out there we drive out
there
and that I forgot
my you know an hour and a half away from
home like well where's the closest door
so and after the first
zillion whatever
right right Josh don't
need4
now pisses me off they come into town
right everyone gets all sight and they
put the butcher the Baker and the
Candlestick maker out of business
because they undercut them and then what
they do is they Curry favor by going
every boy scout group every football
team every cheerleading squad every you
know Garden Club then they all give them
donations you know and if you go into
Walmart when they come into a store
they'll have a whole list on the wall w
a they gave to all the local charities
but to do that they had to earn money
and that puts out some of these other
local businesses so it's a you know it's
a it's a tough
one my personal opinion is Walmart
didn't order hurt this country by
putting people out of business by buying
few products from overseas put American
manufacturers out of business I'm big
for you well and that's like I I was
talking I was talking to a friend of
mine about the U minimum w bills we have
coming up this year and um this was
after President Biden put the admin
executive order in for $15 an hour
contractors and he thought that was just
$15 blanket across the country and he's
like oh man that's really going to put
you know Main Street out of business and
setting aside whether that's true or not
like think of what you're talking about
with Walmart Amazon in particular like I
think Amazon last year I don't know what
percentage of the diaper Market that
they cornered but they choked out almost
everybody Amazon yeah cuz it didn't used
to be toys or R had
to they they sold more diapers than
anybody and then you're right Walmart
came into them and then Amazon came in
too yeah I think Amazon's a problem
personally
uh it when do you when you know and how
and how Monopoly and as you see with the
uh GameStop stuff going on right now a
lot of the uh all the Reddit stuff oh I
love that so much what do you think you
think is right you think the government
is trying to I want to go buy a GameStop
shirt I'm so did that oh
yeah the guy figure out how to beat yeah
is that hilarious like yeah no because
if you the rules are the rules yeah
exactly rul you know my libertarian
friends have that like non-aggression
principle where you enter into agreement
that's the agreement so the agreement
cannot be one way for those hedge fund
houss and then another way for
Representatives you are on YouTube being
recorded I'm sorry I just want to let
okay but the fact that
like about it after they got some of
their own
medicine
the game is the game if you want to play
it they were trying to choke GameStop
out by
short I don't think Walmart has any care
that
were
[Music]
it's
not no Robin Hood made it so you can't
buy any more stock you can only sell
what you have so GameStop share has
today right you're being
recorded too that's fine I fully support
what those rators are doing with
GameStop and I don't care knows it yeah
that's
[Music]
more
sh
another
[Music]
one pictures
yeah
well I can sympathize because mine gets
Tangled not only in the glasses put in
my
heing try to take it off hey comes
dangling from your
ear batter hanging down still in your
she can we supposed to still be signing
in sign in anym sign in downstairs
security guess I
should all right ladies and gentlemen
it's 2:56 we'll be starting in 4
oops we're going to be starting the
minutes
you
I have a few announcements for the
members of the labor
Committee just going to wait a minute
faces
I appreciate everyone's uh diligence
today I know it's been a long day but um
I hope you like having a couple long
days instead of a large number of short
days I have scheduled uh you'll see in
the calendar uh five bills for next
Thursday is our
date um workers compensation for heart
and lung disease for
firefighters relative to paid sick time
and then in the afternoon
three all three of the
um bills relating to
um minimum
wage bill so you'll see that in your
calendar for next
Thursday um we'll be starting at n9ine
o'clock if anyone else who is um not
here today who is planning on being here
in person please let me know right now
uh 1 two 3 4 5 67 office it's relatively
comfortable uh we could easily add
another five or six um the room could
probably hold 10 but I think we're at a
a good Comfort level here with everyone
who's here uh it is relatively safe we
have four different HEPA filters going
on here that you folks probably can't
see um there's masks and hand sanitizer
outside the room as well as individual
security is walking up and down the
hallways uh uh making sure only people
that should be here are here and that
they're wiping down the surfaces so in
case you were you are
wondering um any questions of anyone in
the committee of the
chair yes representative
s um I um noticed that those bills that
you scheduled for the afternoon of um uh
next Thursday two of them definitely are
minimum wage bills the third one um
addresses the minimum um uh salary for
um uh the U
uh some of the professors at the U
associate colleges um and I don't know
that that pairs well with the other
two um so I I just would suggest you
might want to take a look at that and
out
Mr
chairman representative K uh I I have no
objection to that scheduling of of that
bill no I I do you know I having read it
um I'll see what I can do uh the the the
rule 67 allows me to call both of the
the minimum wage bills I can have them
introduced
um I don't know let me think about it
I'll talk to representative Sullivan
we'll see uh maybe I just postpone that
to the next day um we can open and close
that hearing and or
just you know it all depends it all
depends how long those this hearing
lasts those two hearings on the um
minimum wage the origin I looked at it
to be honest with you I took a look at
it and since it required 75% of the
salary received um so um yeah I guess
we'll have to play it by year if only
one person testifies on behalf of it uh
we'll know it's something that we can
open open it
um but thank you for pointing that out
questions uh Mr chairman uh that
particular morning I have I'm a
co-sponsor of another bill that's in
another committee and that's I know this
happens a lot with 400 members and only
so many committee so I I may have to be
in the other place uh for part of that
morning that is a 590 FN that I have
schedule between 10 and 11 or 10 and
um no I think it was the early morning
there there a there's a something in
education what I'm a co-sponsor
of
so I just want to just want to let you
know as far as my tech back backup uh I
I may not be available for the first uh
for the first bill or so understood
understood thank you all right a little
late here till
302 oh unless I sorry unless I missed
anybody everyone else is
good all right it is
302 hearing for House Bill 231 relative
rights
[Applause]
and Christina I do not have a state
representative on my list that will be
um uh introducing the bill do we have a
representative um in the queue who is
bill not
anyone
um representative Vice chairman um see
could you please introduce House Bill uh
231 please thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is representative Brian
seaworth I represent pimbrook and Chai
Chester and I would like to introduce HB
231 relative to workplace lactation
rights
and sign up great thank you very much
representative now hear from the next
person who has um signed up to
speak uh if they are available
Christina anney Masashi New Hampshire
Commission of Human Rights I apologize
on
Anne
Masashi okay I see y I see your name
okay great can can you hear me yes we
can excellent um good afternoon everyone
um my name is Anie Mal Anie Malachi I
can't pronounce my own name today
too it's contagious I think it's lack of
caffeine is what's happening um so I'm
the executive director for the
commission for human rights and I'm here
for informational purposes um while just
a little background about the commission
um we're not taking a specific position
on this bill um but there could be some
uh items for thought and there could
also be questions that um the uh the
group may have um relative to how this
bill would uh and the changes U
connected within could
um
uh what the changes could do to RSA 354
d a um for a bit of context the
commission for human rights as a state
agency we were established in
1965 um as I said by RSA
354a for the purpose of eliminating
discrimination against people who have
been historically victimized by
discrimination um and uh thus this has
created protected
classes we also have jurisdiction over
the areas of employment public
accommodations um housing and education
was recently added to our RSA as of
2019 and the commission is a neutral
receive investigate and pass upon
complaints of illegal discrimination in
the areas that I mentioned before um and
relative to um HB
231 there are some
areas uh towards the end that would have
uh statutory language
changes
and the there was a Senate Bill earlier
this week um and I believe it was Senate
Bill
69 I'm sorry Senate Bill
60 yes Senate Bill 69 that deal that
deals with pregnancy the language
contained in that bill um is a bit more
clear and more concise um and would be
more lines with the work that we are
currently doing um Senate Bill 69 it
just restates in a very clear way the
work that the commission currently does
whereas the uh the specifics here um
make it a bit more
confusing and if there are any um
additional questions that you might have
for me I will certainly be here for the
length of the hearing to answer any
questions and if it's possible if I have
something to interject I would hopefully
be able to raise my hand and at some
point be recognized thank you
all thank you do I have any questions
for the speaker um anyone on Zoom have
any
questions seeing none anyone here in the
committee
room I do have a question for you um and
you may I apologize I was getting a a
text from the legislature here uh and I
and I missed a couple sentences of what
you
said um the bill that was heard two days
ago in the
Senate um that I
believe the hearing went a couple hours
and then the information I read was
correct they actually
did um exec and ought to pass is that an
identical Bill to
231 so to thank you for the question um
so a a bit of History um last uh last
session Senator Martha Fuller Clark um
had a bill that was um uh
sb68 and that went through um quite a
few hearings and with covid everything
changed um
and there's a so and just bear with me
just one moment because there there are
two bills that are so similar and I
apologize because I believe I'm getting
the two confused okay um I am as well
and that's why I I I asked and yeah so
I'm looking at my notes right now okay
so the the two bills are Senate Bill 68
and there's also Senate Bill 69 okay
Senate Bill
69 is um there were and and of course
the hearings for both were also on
Tuesday and they were backto back um so
I apologize for not having all of that
ready um so Senate Bill
69 is the um complete version
of uh this house bill 231 and what I
mean by that is uh Senator Marsha Fuller
Clark along she's the chair or was the
chair of the lactation Council on that
Council there are quite a few um
agencies as well as um New Hampshire
businesses that have a seat at the table
there was full consensus as they worked
through what the bill should be and um
Dave J of the Bia gave testimony um on
uh sb69 on Tuesday and on the lactation
Council which has since been dissolved
um the commission has two seats so one
of our investigators participates or
participated with the Council and also
um a local attorney who practices before
the commission uh was in participation
as well so there are some other state
agencies that participated in creating s
sp69 and that one is certainly um the
language is uh something
that it doesn't involve uh RSA
354a which would be preferred um and the
language is something that um a a group
of people work together and there was
consensus along with the business
Community to make S sp69 what it is um
with HB
231 and the redefinition in some of the
areas here for um for RSA 354a which is
the commission statute um the language
um is not as clean as in
sb68 and that's why it's confusing s
sp68 deals with pregnancy and that
language is very clean um and I worked
with the the senator I previously it was
a last session and then it got tabled
and so it's been brought back so the
commission worked hand inand with the
senator to make sure that the language
was clean and and very clear so that
small businesses large businesses
attorneys would have um clear guidance
on what was needed relative to pregnancy
so I know it's a bit disjointed so two
different bills or are basically
covering the same
thing did that answer your question
doeses read up on both Senate Bill 68
and 69 to
see clear on the differences any other
if if I could answer one more thing um
so in an early draft of the bill that
Senator Fuller Clark put forth some of
the the majority of the content from
this from HB 231 was that early draft um
prior to consensus building and and
information gathering and that turned
into Senate Bill
69 if that's helpful and so with
that the commission's RSA was
removed and made into a separate bill um
confusion
hopefully understood um I see
representative
kahill has a question for you go ahead
representative yes uh thank you Mr chair
and thank you Miss Malachi is there
anything in House Bill 231 that would
need to be added to
sb69 to have the best possible product
no to answer your question and thank you
for that um
sb69 is a cleaner product um and I
believe it it serves the purpose of what
we're looking to do in terms of
pregnancy protection and then um X SB
sb68 serves the purpose of HB 231 and
SB um 69 cleans up the language that is
attempted in in this one for the
commission statute however it's a lot
cleaner and it doesn't it doesn't
include um language that that isn't
necessary if that makes sense follow up
Mr chairman follow up uh so if we were
to uh retain this bill just in case
something went wrong that wouldn't cost
us anything correct us meaning money I
me no I mean there wouldn't be any
downside to doing that if we held this
for next year just in case the other
bills didn't make it across the finish
line so um thank you for the redirect
there um if we if if the other one did
not make it across the finish line and
if HB 231 was held over then it would
need to go through the exact same
changes as s
sp69
has
completed so we we could just as well
vote to itl this bill today on some
other
occasion uh that would certainly be well
within the purview of the legislature I
dare not tell you what to do thank you
there okay any other further questions
for the
speaker
I see none thank you very much thank you
I'd like to Now call our second uh
speaker uh Rudy Ogden M Department of
Labor Commissioner assistant
us I am um I would just being mindful of
everyone's time and keeping it short I'm
happy to hear anyone's questions but I
would Echo the sentiments just offered
that essentially I think that you'll see
Senate Bill 69 offering a cleaner
product on on this um specifically the
department with this bill does have some
concerns due to the lack of clarity on
what break time should be provided uh so
again I just echoing director Malachi's
thoughts I think Senate Bill 69 cleans
up some of the concepts for your
consideration thank you uh commissioner
Ogden this is uh will infantine um did I
read correctly
uh there are 14 sponsors on um the
Senate bills and that both did pass um
executive session on Tuesday after the
hearing yes my understanding is that it
was it was exact I'd want to confirm
that but that was what I had heard at
least earlier this week thank you any
questions of any members here in the LLB
for uh Ry Ogden Comm Ogden seeing none
online any uh Representatives online
have any questions for assistant
commissioner
Ogden I do don't see any Christina if
you see anyone that I have
missed I do not we do have a third uh
speaker Miss Kate
Frederick from rustic events
nhbrc could you uh ple please uh State
the name again yes it's Kate Frederick
thank
you uh Miss pedrick if you are um
unmuted and ready to go I feel free to
uh address the
committee thank you chairman um I have
house rep ael's introduction that he
sent me to read for you all if you would
like me to do that I
can you like go
ahead um chairman infantine and members
of the labor industrial and
rehabilitative services committee I am
representative Richard AEL Grafton 13
serving Lebanon primary sponsor of HB
231 relative to workplace lactation
rights the bill directs employers to
provide reasonable accommodations for
employees who are
lactating the bill before you is based
on a Senate bill from last session that
never reached the house because of
shutdowns and delays caused by the covid
pandemic very similar bills have been
passed by the house in earlier
years most recently the governor signed
into law a statute that applies only to
State
Employees experienc with state employees
shows this policy works well with
positive benefits for the employer
employees and their
families h231 would extend the same
reasonable accommodations to private
employers not all already covered by
federal law and to their
employees federal law already covers
large employers but not medium and
smaller workplaces where most New
Hampshire employees work let me
Summarize each aspect of this
bill workplace lactation rights section
one defines key terms and
coverage sections
two through six addresses provision of
reasonable accomodations note that the
word reasonable before
accommodations section seven exempts
places of employment of fewer than six
employees if such requirements would
impose an undue
hardship sections 8 through 11 possibly
further describe interactions and
actions part two addresses the role of
the state commission for human rights
under RSA 354 addressing lactation and
breastfeeding Mr chair and committee
members I sponsored HB 231 because I
strongly believe this bill is pro bus
pro- employee and pro- family it helps
businesses recruit and retain quality
employees in an important demographic it
builds loyalty in employees who
appreciate their employers reasonable
accommodations it reduces the time and
cost from employee turnover
and needing to find and train
Replacements it's a winwin win as
working mothers are able to stay with
their
employer the sponsors value the
committee's work to make h231 the best
Bill it can be we are open to making
modifications to improve this
legislation and move it successfully
through committee and the floor of House
and
[Music]
Senate um I would like to continue with
my own testimony if that is possible
yes go
you just turn to the right
page so my name is Kate Frederick I
founded the New Hampshire breastfeeding
rights
Coalition I am a former New Hampshire
state employee I worked as an instructor
teaching psychology at Granite State
College I worked as a certifying officer
with New Hampshire employe security
where I adjudicated unemployment claims
and I worked in Conway New Hampshire as
a child support officer while I was
pregnant collecting child support
payments from people that were
overdue I was fired After experiencing
pregnancy and lactation
discrimination this was in
2012 the Human Rights Commission was
unable to take my claim at that time
they didn't have
jurisdiction the new Hampshire
Department of Labor was unable to take
my claim as there are no State statutes
protecting workplace accommodations for
lactation the federal US Department of
Labor was also unable to take my
claim the EEOC was able to take my
claim over eight years later my lawsuit
is currently in the New Hampshire
Supreme
Court it has not yet been heard on the
merits it has been litigated over
whether or not I have the right to sue
immunity what this bill does is it takes
the last eight years I'm sorry seven
years of bills that we have worked on
with the
Bia with Republicans with Democrats with
Libertarians with
progressives with citizens that are both
small business employees ERS and mothers
that are
lactating I have been involved in all of
those
bills the previous Prime sponsors have
been house rep Ed
Butler Senator Martha fo
Clark Senator Jeb Bradley two of his
bills passed forming the advisory
Council on
lactation Senator Fuller Clark chaired
The Advisory Council on lactation and
pregnancy and I served as clerk for the
first year and I was a member for two
years I'm currently a student at Vermont
law
school and I also am a student at
dartmouth's Medical School in health
policy the real issue here is whether or
not New Hampshire supports lactating
employees when they don't have lactation
rates during work hours only pumping
rates but smokers can't can't be
discriminated against for needing to
smoke during work
hours I don't know if you submitted the
Behemoth 55 page report I submitted by
email it goes over everything every
legislator has asked over the eight
years about this type of Bill including
how does an employer create a lactation
room if they work at Dunkin Donuts or in
a mechanics auto mechanic shop or they
only have two
employees
um to address some of the testimony that
was already given I have never met with
M Malachi um I hope to we have a meeting
scheduled very
soon
sb68 was previously Senator Bradley's
bill before the pandemic it is now
Senator Hennessy's bill that is the
pregnancy rate
bill for that
bill M Malachi myself and Attorney Megan
racklin from a better balance Law Firm
are all meeting to discuss an amendment
to the pregnancy bill which was
suggested by Senator
Bradley S sp69 I testified that is the
other that's the pumping only bill so
that Bill explicitly states that it
excludes breastfeeding during work hours
and there was testimony that was
um opposition it was opposite there was
two different people that testified
saying opposite things so the sponsor of
that bill Senator
Whitley said that s sp69 does not
exclude
breastfeeding it just excluded
breastfeeding from the definition of
expressing
milk another person testified saying we
are not recommending breastfeeding
during work
h231 is compliant with federal and state
laws and the EEOC enforcement guidances
I know I'm going on here do you want me
to
continue just a few more minutes please
okay thank
you what I testified about s sp69 is
that it may not be lawful and the
reasons why are because there's an EEOC
enforcement guidance on pregnancy and
related medical conditions and it states
that discriminating against an employee
for pumping and breastfeeding is
discriminatory s
sp69 serves to fill a gap in the federal
law that left out protections for
teachers restaurant workers
managers and employees whose babies
don't latch right away maybe they need
surgery on their mouth on their cheek on
their tongue they can't
latch so that bill sb69 closes the Gap
only for hourly workers this bill is
more inclusive it closes the gap for
everyone the question I have is
how can you spend so much money on
supporting
breastfeeding and exclude breastfeeding
just this week
$9.5 million was put into the 2021
breastfeeding the Department of Health
and Human Services and the New Hampshire
breastfeeding task force just gave out
grants to create 43 different lactation
stations at businesses all over New New
Hampshire I don't see how you can
exclude breastfeeding and support
breastfeeding at the same
time there are also other laws like
title s the Civil Rights Act which
includes the pregnancy Discrimination
Act that I I believe
sb69 may not be um taken into
consideration and there's also four or
five different case law that have come
out that establish that lactation is a
pregnancy thank you happy to answer any
questions thank you for uh uh sharing
your story uh and for your testimony do
I have any questions amongst any members
lob seeing none do I have any questions
amongst the uh Representatives on Zoom I
do see one hand I believe that
thank you
um if I'm hearing you correctly you're
saying that um um there are some things
that are in um House Bill
231 um that you believe ought to be
incorporated into the final bill um I we
also heard a few minutes ago that sb69
is a cleaner bill um would it would it
make more sense for us to amend s sp69
to address um any existing faults or are
you suggesting that s uh HB 231 is a
better bill for us to uh um Carry
forward thank you for your question
representative Sullivan I think the best
idea would be to merge the two bills
whichever number you want to
keep um I know rep AEL and Senator
Whitley the sponsors of those two bills
are meeting the first week of February
to go over
that um what I testified for with
regards to sb69 the pumping only Bill is
that these bills should be merged and
that I don't believe sb69 is lawful I
unconstitutional
followup followup Mr chairman yes yes
followup yeah
um Do You Believe sb69 could be amended
to make it lawful absolutely I think
that everybody is willing to work
together there perhaps have been
scheduling conflicts that haven't made
that possible this bill was originally
drafted by Martha Fuller
Clark um a week
after my lawsuit was heard in the New
Hampshire Supreme
Court and it was was pulled after U Miss
Malachi um spoke to Senator filler Clark
um and we tried to work on it after that
and now rep Abel has taken it over um
Senator Fuller former Senator Fuller
Clark will also be at the meeting in
February if she can attend she's been
invited
um I've made this my whole life I am so
so dedicated to these issues that I'm
going into $200,000 worth of debt to
become a lawyer and I love it I had no
idea that this was my passion when this
happened to me but I can tell you how
horrible it has been to lose my
income for my husband to have to carry
our family for my parents to have to dip
into their retirement money to help us
because we couldn't make it on our own
for the backlash that I received
um for bringing up the
lawsuit etc etc what it has done is made
me more active in the legislature and I
have been able to work with legislators
from every
party and it's been an invaluable
experience that I've enjoyed very much I
hope to continue to do that and I know
we can find a solution I know Reb Abel
and myself both feel will make any
amendments necessary to get something
passed the problem
is for the last seven years every Bill
we've put forth all the accommodations
in them to actually help lactating
employees have been removed the only
Provisions that have passed have been to
form an advisory Council on lactation
and
pregnancy so it's time to get something
past you know it's a pandemic right now
as you all know and it turns out that
the World Health Organization
recommends even mothers that have been
infected with covid continue direct
access breastfeeding because the
antibodies pass through the milk to the
baby it's like vaccinating the
baby so it's kind of pandemic urgent to
pass this
legislation um and I hope to be as
done
speaker I see none in the Legislative
Office Building I don't see any on Zoom
Christina have I missed any questions
being to any hands raised or anything U
Miss Malachi has her hand raised in the
attendees um box but other than that no
one
else okay I uh I will uh is is M Malaki
asking a question of the speaker or
she'd like to testify again
I'm not sure all I see is the hand okay
uh please acknowledge M
Malachi
okay is M thank you thank you very much
for acknowledging me I I would like to
um add some additional testimony if I
may okay just a moment please um thank
you thank you to the previous speaker
Kate uh thank you very much uh Fredick
um for uh your testimony I will now um
recognize uh Ani
for additional testimony thank you um I
appreciate that I I wanted to say before
we moved forward it is um very important
I I believe that we clarify and we
compare apples to apples and oranges to
oranges and
um the HB 231 although uh Miss Frederick
worked on on that um the the legis
islative information there um what she
stated was was accurate that it was
something that she was a part of with uh
Senator uh former Senator fer Clark um
the difference is that HB 231 was an
initial draft and not a completed work
and
so
sb69 which is moving its way through now
is the completed work and that means
that the eyes have been d the Tes have
been crossed that the commission has
been consulted regarding any changes
that potentially need to be made the
commission is the um authoritative body
we are the ones that will take a charge
of discrimination in whatever area in
the areas of course that we have
jurisdiction um and if a person comes to
us and and has a charge that they would
like to file um due to conf
confidentiality we can't
disclose what the um background
information of that charge is um
everyone that comes to us feels that
they have a charge they may have a
charge or they may not have a charge um
but that is something that has to be
done they have to meet the the legal
standards and the burdens that we have
as we move through the process in order
for um for us to complete to for for us
to docket a charge of
discrimination um it is also important
to understand that the work that was
done on S sp69 previously and what is
present what has already been presented
as I said before is the completed work
um I have I will I don't have any
meetings scheduled at this point um I
will be reaching out um to the senator
um Senator Hennessy and I will go from
there to determine who needs to who I'll
need to talk to in terms of any
amendments for 69 um but as um Mr Ogden
stated um and as I've stated earlier
that their 60 sb69 and HB
231 um do not need to be combined of the
two the stronger more complete more
finished polished most most consensus
would be
sb69 and so even if the word breast
feeding is left out um it is already
covered in our statute and of the
charges that we take we take very few in
the areas in the area of pregnancy
discrimination and if one looks at our
statute they'll have a clearer
understanding of what pregnancy means um
I think there was a little confusion
there that um that was shared in
testimony um that's not 100% accurate as
to what we cover um breastfeeding is
covered already and um and the way the
statute Works New Hampshire covers um
smaller businesses so you have to have
at least six employees so um that's the
way the law is applied so we don't want
to be more burdensome at the commission
than the state of New Hampshire is on
businesses and uh although we enforce
the law we certainly want to partner
with businesses to help them meet
whatever burden they need to meet we
want to work with employees and other
individuals so that they understand what
their place of business or what um a
hotel or or some place of accommodation
what their responsibilities are to them
as a citizen so I wanted to make that
very very clear that there um that
there's some confusion in the language
um although very emotive testimony um in
HB 231 the clearer cleaner more concise
with the most consensus and with the
agreement of the business industry
business and industry as well as the
department of lab labor is going to be
sb69 so thank you very much for
indulging me and if you have any
additional questions I'm available for
that as
well representative
Sullivan thank you
um let me try this um would I be correct
in in thinking that um in your opinion
SB uh 69 is good to go as is however
if through meetings with any of these
interested
parties um a useful amendment is uh uh
suggested you would be open to that yes
that is thank you very much for the
question representative Sullivan and the
answer to that would be yes it is ready
to go as it is however after meeting um
if it is deemed that um the senator
would like to add something um then we
would certainly look at that and agree
to it um and our job my job here is to
make sure that anything that's added
doesn't undo something else or become
overly burdensome or additionally
354a all right thank you for your
testimony do we have any additional
questions for miss
baky seeing none in the
Zoom Christina do we have any additional
questions or any
speakers um I just received word that um
so we have a Roberta burner who's got
her a hand up but I believe it's rep AEL
um under the name of his wife so he has
up okay I will recognize representative
Abel representative AEL this is uh
representative will infantine uh uh we
did have someone call in we did uh
introduce the bill on your behalf
representative seaworth did that and
then we had some testimony uh written
testimony that was read on your behalf
yes thank thank you can you all hear me
um I I experienced some at the last
minute some technical problems that uh I
couldn't connect the the the the
appropriate way um you have heard uh you
have heard then my what I how I would
have introduced the bill um I still
believe that if if if I may make a
suggestion you can take it uh if if you
so desire if you wish um I believe that
the best uh um the best way forward at
this time would be it would be to retain
the bill and let us work through some
some things with with the Senate um so
that we don't lose we don't lose the
bill um I I I disagree with the uh
previous speaker that the Senate bill is
is necessarily clearer uh than this but
the point the the the point is to get
leg ation through so that we're helping
the people of of New Hampshire um and
the employers and the employees and
their families so I I I would hope you
would not it itl this um but if but
for I don't know if we lost you
representative able got off on a
sentence you're still there I am still
here I sorry
uh I I I was saying I I was saying thank
you very much uh Mr chair uh I was
saying that I hope you will consider
retaining the
bill so that we can continue to work on
it in case there's a problem with the
Senate bill and find a solution to the
um to the few issues that still need to
be
clarified were you able to hear that sir
yes I am thank you repres thank you um
any questions from the members here in
the LLB to representative AEL seeing
none any members of the uh committee on
Zoom have any questions for
representative
AEL seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you sir all right
with no other hands no other questions
no other
comments going once going twice I'm
going to close the hearing on House Bill
231 after reading just a few here bear
with me uh individuals who are have
signed in
um um representative Mr Speaker just to
be fair we you permitted miss an Mal to
speak twice and I on my board I see Miss
Kate Frederick's hands still
or re raed I don't know if that's
intentional or
not you know I expected this to happen
and I have a answer for
you uh Miss uh Christina is uh Miss
Frederick on available is she there she
is okay uh Miss Frederick I I'm going to
let you uh testify and provide some
additional testimony uh please bear with
me I do not want to have a um a a I'm
not going to let anyone else speak of
the you Miss Malachi afterwards I don't
want to get into a
dis an argu uh a debate between the two
of you I respect both of your opinion
I'm going to let you speak as well um um
about anything that you feel appropriate
Al
righty thank you chairman I'm actually
what I wanted to do was read you
testimony from other New Hampshire
employees that have been discriminated
against it's in the report I sent
you however um I'm sort of sensing that
maybe it would be best if I didn't just
read it to you you have it um I agree
with rep AEL that um in case sb69 gets
killed because it may not be
lawful then HB 231 would still be
alive um and perhaps we could
amend s sp69 together if all the parties
are willing to work together um if you
want me to read some of the testimony
from other New Hampshire employees I can
uh if you if they have been sent to us
uh we will read them uh trust me uh I I
know I can speak for myself and I'm sure
many of the other committee members we
do are do de we do are very diligent
about reading what is sent to us so I'd
appreciate for this ense of time but I
do have one question for you is my
understanding having read the article of
yesterdays or the Tuesdays that there's
an acknowledgement by a few members that
while the bill was
um exec ought to pass they admitted
there were some changes that could be
made and they were willing to amend um
the bill is that how you understand it
great I'm sorry did you cut off um I
said I'm just hearing of that now from
you but I think that's great I I think
that is is accurate um the best my
ability any other uh
testimony Miss
Francis Frederick sorry oh I'm sorry no
I'm done thank you so much you're very
welcome thank you very
much anything else anybody else all
right I'm going to uh read this um uh
the people who have signed in in support
and opposition uh representative uh
Terry Roy is opposed representative
Rebecca McWilliams is in
support uh um Nicole 40 is in support
Glen bracket uh working people of New
Hampshire AFL CIO is in
support uh Lucius partial is in support
Carrie Anderson is in support Lewis
Spencer supports jeie bruska uh ACLU New
Hampshire is in support jeie torpy is in
support Jun Garen is in support Mel
pinen boach is in support Susan Richmond
is in support of the Bill Mora willing
is in support Eric Ratburn is in support
of everything I think we've done today
uh Katherine Spielman is in support
James Spielman as support Moren ellerman
as support
support all right ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much I'm closing the
hearing on House Bill
231 uh any questions of the chair before
we adjourn
seeing none in the L thank you seeing
none online thank you very much folks
we'll see you next Thursday you uh just
in case I thought I think I've given it
uh that's not even that's not even my
phone
number my cell phone number is
9779 nice job well 493 9779 I'll blame
it on lingering anesthesia um if you
need me for
anything all right folks thank work
today thank you CHR will good to see
everybody thank you
good